Does that new band,
he mails and uh,
I,
I do a fucking really shitty beat box.
I'm feeling that money coming in
already,
Brian.
We got a winning combination.
We need to put this shit on wax ready.
The Joe Rogan experience is brought to
you by [inaudible] dot com.
That's o n n I t,
makers of Alpha brain shroom,
tech sport.
And You keep doing them.
And I was kind of fun.
Just shroom tech immune to do what are
you going to do?
New Mood.
Another favorite new mood is actually a
five htp and l trip to fan a supplement
that uh,
aids your body and its ability to
produce serotonin.
So it actually can make you happy.
This is one that is a not to be taken by
people that are on antidepressants
though.
If you're on antidepressants,
apparently there's an issue with a
creating too much,
too much serotonin,
too much,
five htp.
So you should be careful if you're on a
few on an Ssri,
don't,
uh,
don't take new load.
But if you are not a safe,
natural,
healthy,
you don't have to worry about it.
Nothing dangerous.
Um,
all the supplements,
that new mood,
all of them have a,
the first 30 orders or the first 30
pills,
the first order have a 100 percent money
back guarantee.
You don't have to return anything.
You just say this shit didn't work and
you get your money back.
The idea behind that is no one's trying
to rip you off.
We're only trying to sell you the very
best supplements possible.
All supplements that I personally
believe in,
all things that I took long before I
ever got involved in on it.
Um,
I've been a vitamin junkie and a
nutrition junkie for a long time because
there's a,
there's a difference.
There's an unquestionable difference in
how your body responds when you feed it.
Good nutrients and you take care of it.
And there's a lot of science behind all
this stuff,
especially nootropics.
There's plenty of studies that show
benefits of nootropics and we're working
on our own now.
I'm a double blind placebo study and
we'll,
we'll let all the details.
It takes a long time to hook something
like that.
Or is it because they're all blind?
No,
that's a scientific method.
Brian,
this is not for blind.
He seems like it takes a long time for
those double blind blindfolds off
project.
Be Faster.
Yeah.
I don't think you understand what the
fuck it means,
son.
Anyway,
we also have kettle bells,
battle ropes.
If use a codename Rogan,
you get 10 percent off any supplements.
The battle ropes in the kettle bells,
whoever that code doesn't work because
we sell them literally as cheap as we
can.
Um,
so go to on it.
Use a code name,
Rogan,
buy yourself some supplements.
You dirty bitches were also brought to
you by desk squad dot TV.
If you go to [inaudible] dot tv,
see like the cat shirt that I had on
yesterday or one of the ones that you'll
see all over this place,
the,
the logos,
but uh,
Brian has two versions of them for sale.
Um,
and uh,
all the money goes to support,
uh,
the,
the desk squad podcast network,
which is on the itunes or aren't you?
Dirty bitches,
which is the only place where you can
see the ice house chronicles this
weekend.
Oh,
this Wednesday rather.
Yeah.
This weekend would have be in Toronto
Hollow,
but uh,
this Wednesday we have a fucking gnarly
show here at the ice house.
We got Doug Benson,
we've got Duncan Trussell,
we got Brian Red Band,
we got Joey Diaz,
we got dom irrera.
Is that it?
Greg Fitzsimmons to.
It's going to be fucking crazy.
And we also went Friday.
If you're in town in La.
Yeah.
Who's on Friday?
Well,
we got clown vis,
which is clown Elvis France.
I liked how you lead strong Gareth from
this,
that new a MTV show and Francisco Ramos
who is confused by a Francisco Kurth
member.
We had him on a podcast and it was the
wrong guy that's supposed to be part of
those Pablo Francisco.
That's right.
Right now we're friends.
So
that's cool.
Do sometimes shit just works out.
Yeah.
Anyway,
uh,
go to desk squad pv and all the
information is there,
right?
All the posters for shows and uh,
all the information for a tee shirt
sales aren't you?
Fucking freaks.
Rich Roll is here.
We're going to get busy sending it
down to the bottom of this thing.
Experience my day podcasts by night
when I did a podcast with Robb Wolf,
who is the Paleo Diet Guy,
uh,
one of the first things that happened
was that I got an immediate influx of,
of vegans who had to set Robb Wolf
Straight because rob wolf said some
crazy shit.
Like I told them,
I drank a Kale shake every morning and
it makes me feel great.
Gives me a lot of energy.
He's like,
no,
you got to eat bacon and eggs cigarettes
and you gotta get your Dick Sucked by
truckers.
He wasn't my superhero.
Yeah,
he,
he said some awesome shit that you
should have bacon,
eggs and coffee in the morning.
And that's a good way to get your day
started.
A lot of people didn't want to hear
that.
A lot of people felt that it was silly.
And you were one of the people that
contacted me and then I lift up your
story and it's pretty fascinating,
man.
You were,
you were like around 40 and you were at
a shape.
Yeah,
I mean,
I was,
uh,
I had been an athlete in college.
I was a swimmer in college,
but uh,
it Kinda got away from me after that,
you know,
when,
when colleges over,
that was kind of the end of that
athletic chapter and,
you know,
life goes on and,
I went to law school and then it's just
about the job and get married and having
kids and you know,
climbing the corporate ladder and all
that kind of stuff and you know,
in the wake of that,
you know,
lost sight of being fit and being
healthy and you know,
it was pretty much a couch potato,
depressed,
lethargic,
a little bit lost in life,
you know,
how it goes.
So,
uh,
I decided I had to uh,
take it back.
I had a little bit of a,
of a health scare that kind of triggered
me to take,
to do something about it.
And so what,
what action did you take specifically?
Well,
I mean,
I wish I could,
you know,
say ran off to the library and got a
bunch of books and,
you know,
read all the Paleo books and read all
the Vegan books and did a double blind
study with people with double blindfolds
on and,
and,
you know,
figuring out the right way to do it.
And,
you know,
that's not what happened.
I mean,
I,
I fumbled around for awhile trying to
figure out what would work for me,
but the first thing I did,
um,
my wife is like,
she's big into yoga and healing and
meditation and she's like,
you know,
she's constantly reading like crazy
spiritual texts and you know,
she's pretty well schooled in
alternative thinking and lifestyle and
all that kind of stuff.
And you know,
if you were to open the refrigerator is
pretty clear like kind of food she was
eating and what I was eating,
which was essentially crap.
So,
uh,
but she would do like a juice cleanse
pretty much every year,
you know.
And that was fine for her.
But that was definitely not something
that I was ever interested in doing.
But,
you know,
it was kind of desperate and I thought,
maybe I'll,
uh,
maybe I'll try that.
And so I just sort of reached out to her
and I said,
you know,
I think I want to do that,
and she hooked me up with,
we got all these crazy herbs and you
know,
we got a juicer and the whole thing and
kind of dialed it in and you know,
I did that for like five days,
kind of a,
not like the,
you know,
in Hollywood,
a lot of people do like the Cayenne
pepper thing or whatever.
Yeah.
I mean that's like a starvation thing.
So it wasn't like that.
It was like I kind of weaned myself off
food for a couple of days and just did
juice for a couple of days and then kind
of lean back into food.
But it was a pretty like,
eyeopening experience,
you know,
like the first couple of days I was
like,
it was like I was in Rehab,
man.
It's like buckled over on the couch,
like detox.
I'm like,
shit,
I could barely move.
What was your diet like before that?
Like what was standard
cheeseburgers?
Yeah,
I mean she's,
you know,
fast food all the time,
man,
you know,
dominoes,
Pizza,
Pizza Hut,
Wendy's,
Jack in the box late at night,
coming home from work,
just it didn't matter.
And you know,
part of that was because when I was in,
when I was swimming in college,
you know,
I'm training like four hours a day and
you're,
you know,
you're 19,
20 years old or whatever.
And just it was just about how many
calories can I put down the throat and
trying to fill myself up,
you know,
it didn't really matter and you know,
you can get away with that stuff,
you know,
and I did for a long time,
but you know,
it catches up to you.
But those habits,
you form those habits that carry with
you and they're,
you know,
they're hard to break.
Yeah.
We really are a creature of habit.
That's a,
it's a strange thing that even bad
habits like gambling,
like people that become gambling
addicts,
it really is some sort of like a,
uh,
like a,
like a hijacking of reward systems and
giving you this,
this rush towards something that really
doesn't make any sense and there's also
the comfort factor that comes and
repeating patterns.
It's like your brain knows how to do it.
It's done it before.
Let's fucking around just keep
doing the same shit you've been doing
and just,
you know,
blow off the gym and take a nap and go
beat off and you know,
just do,
do,
do the same stupid shit you've been
doing.
It's really hard for people to like to
move away from that.
Yeah.
You get these like cemented pathways in
your brain and it's just your default.
Like I think you,
you know,
when you were certain behavior patterns
after a while,
you don't even know you're doing it.
You're just like,
it's like your program,
like a computer.
You just follow that pattern every time.
Change is hard,
man.
It is hard and it's,
it's also,
it's hard to find a healthy meal at like
fucking Burger King or Jack in the box.
It's hard to go in there and really get
some nutrients.
You can't happen.
I mean you like you look you like,
do you got a salad?
You've got to sell over there and he
looked at the salad.
You're like,
oh Jesus.
It's all like iceberg lettuce,
assault wilderness and everything's
closed early here in la.
So if you're working late and coming
home like it's sometimes it's the only
option.
Subways,
subways though,
that's,
you know,
all that stuff that they can keep on a
shelf for that long.
None of that is good for you.
So much.
It's way better.
I would imagine if you just got a
chicken sandwich or a on whole wheat or
something like that.
You need to drive throughs and more
drive through siblings if they even have
any at all.
But that would be perfect.
Just dudes talking to you about like
some serious fucking festival nutrition.
You want to,
you want to find the healthier,
you know,
but I mean you gotta I mean I can't
imagine the produce that like subway and
you're such a huge corporation.
You're getting the low rent.
You cannot fuck with in and out Burger
man.
If you had like some like really sexy
tofu lettuce wrap thing that you're
selling,
but right next door was in and out
burger.
You're doomed son.
It's tough,
man.
It goes back to those pathways.
You know,
you smell it.
It's like a fair amount.
Yeah,
it's powerful.
It also goes back to the fact that in
and out it's fucking delicious.
That's a problem too.
You can't deny that shit's delicious,
man.
I did it for years and years and years,
especially in and out,
those fresh burgers so much better than
burgers at like,
you know,
someplace where they nuke it.
Didn't they just have like a little bit
of a scandal there though with some of
their meat.
Did they screwed up?
Yeah.
I thought I remember reading something
about that.
Maybe this might be vegan propaganda
probably.
It wasn't like the Zan.
Remember desk squad coming down on me
like my twitter already exploded.
Your fans are fucking rabid,
tense,
intense following.
I don't know what happened.
Um,
yeah.
I to go to war.
You just rally the troops.
What?
We're trying to build armies.
That's what we're selling kettlebells.
We're selling kettle bells and battle
ropes and selling vitamins and brain
pills and subscribing to youtube videos.
The uh,
yeah,
you were right there in and out burger.
I'm a plant.
Got closed by US da.
A supplied a or a rather than.
Yeah,
the,
the inspectors.
Temporary shut down.
California Meat Company that provided
the beef or the popular in and out
burger chain.
Iu.
That's not good.
No propaganda here,
man.
And also the I of course,
I'm just,
it's always good to have the information
if you say things all the time and I
need to check them so I'd do it with
anybody else has something to.
But the US school lunch program,
they also provided food for them.
Who?
Who fucking.
If you're sourcing that much beef,
you know,
you're a huge company like that.
You're going to have a problem like that
from time to time.
Yeah.
There's a lot of cows involved in that,
huh?
What is.
What are the numbers and something like
that.
Now it's got to be enormous.
Diane Sawyer looks pissed as fuck.
That was the last person you want on TV.
No,
Nancy grace is the last person you want
to talk shit about you angry faced,
but I'm like,
how many cows do you think they use?
Like just in and out a small chain like
in and out.
How many do they use in his day?
Got To be mind blowing.
Yeah.
Whoa.
Really?
Stop and think about that.
It's like the holocaust of cows over
there.
Well,
you know what it is,
man.
We figured out how to make this society
work without people hunting.
It feel like this weird notion that we
have zero connection with how the food
is gathered.
Like that's a really fucking crazy way
to live.
So everybody's like,
yeah,
I'd like meat like meat,
but you don't have to do any of the
stuff that makes you respect the animal.
You don't have to hunt it down.
You don't have to kill it enough to like
be thankful that you got it and bring it
back.
There's none of that anymore.
The system
stem is set up to prevent you from
thinking about it.
You know,
it's almost like grocery stores in a
certain way.
It's analogous to like a Vegas casino
where,
you know,
the casinos,
I don't know if they're pumping the air
conditioning and there's no clocks.
You can't find the exit door.
It's disorienting and the same way like
a grocery store,
everything's perfectly packaged.
It looks clean or what,
whatever,
you know,
you're not,
you're not supposed to think about that.
I was at a grocery store that has a
butcher shop in the back and uh,
they were sawing through a side of beef
and you don't really see that,
you know,
you really rarely see that.
You know,
you would usually get is you get like,
you know,
they have these packages and the state
because already nice and wrapped up and
you go,
this one is a full pound.
That's a good size state.
I'll take that home.
No,
no,
no.
This dude had saw and he was running
meet through the,
so I was like,
yeah,
that's real life son.
That's,
that's our body.
It's not like a steak.
Now there's a body that has to get
chopped up and become sex when we're so
separated from that.
That actual experience of seeing the
animal lose its life and understanding
what it means to eat it.
We're completely separated from really
strange.
Imagine if your job was the guy in the
slaughterhouse,
like doing that cutting throats or
whatever.
I mean,
that's got a tad emotional gotta be mad.
Yes.
It's got to be madness all day.
You're seeing terrified animals and
you're giving them the very thing that
they're terrified of it.
Terrified of losing their lives.
Fucking horrifying.
Yeah.
It's weird man.
And I think you know,
you
know I think you can appreciate is a
deep thinker,
but you know,
food is energy,
man.
It,
it carries a vibration and so when you
put something in your mouth and you know
you're making a decision to take that
vibration into you and so you know what,
what is that vibration?
You know,
when you're taking in a terrorized
animal,
does that affect you?
Is that.
Does that change your perception,
your decision making,
your outlook,
does it not?
I don't know.
It's very good question.
The,
you know the solution though,
it seems to be it's not as simple as
don't eat meat because even if you don't
eat meat,
what are you gonna do with all these
fucking cows?
Are you going to stop them from
breeding?
Are you going to let them starve to
death and die off?
Or they're going to go extinct?
Like how are we going to regulate these
cows?
You're either going to shoot them or
you're going to castrate a bunch of
them.
You're going to have to shoot some of
them because otherwise you're going to
have cows wandering through the streets
everywhere.
Like you got to deal with the fact that
we have to deal with the fact that
you've created a species.
You know,
essentially we've bred cows to this
domestic form from wild cows and you
know,
it's,
we've done it for so long that they're
pretty much helpless.
Without us,
it'd be bad cows.
There's no predators out there.
It's not like we live in fucking Africa
and there's lions running around the
could take care of the cow problem.
It's not going to happen.
You would have a real problem with cows
if we stopped eating them.
Just the fucking sheer numbers that
exist now.
I mean,
unless you could absolutely keep them
from breeding and then you would have to
figure out what we're going to do.
You're going to just let the old ones
die.
You're going to let some of them breed,
you know,
what are you going to do?
No,
it's not.
Absolutely.
Yeah.
There's no easy solution,
but the Vegan solution of not eating the
meat at least removes Karma from your
position.
It moves.
It removes you from interacting with the
terrified animals last moments into for
you to be.
I don't want to say profiting,
benefiting from that.
Well,
I don't know.
I just
speak to my own experience.
You know,
and I know I feel better.
I feel more energized.
I feel like my energy is even in good.
My,
my mood and my outlook is positive and I
think that,
you know,
when you,
when you talk about Vegan and the word
Vegan and what that means,
I mean that means different things to
different people.
You know,
it's a tricky word.
It's
no what it means for a lot of people.
Well,
what it means,
fuck you.
No,
it means it means,
uh,
you,
you run a high risk of them being
annoying.
It doesn't mean that they're ignoring a
lot of friends that are awesome.
Mac Danzig is a Vegan and he's a great
guy,
great guy,
and he's going to be on the podcast
tomorrow again.
We fucked up and the big disaster for
this park and I just sit.
My twitter feed won't still being a lazy
fuck.
People are so silly.
You know,
Max,
a great guy,
awesome guy,
and he's,
you know,
he's got his reasons and they're
intelligent or reasons for being a
Vegan.
However,
there are a few people that do it as
like a sanctimonious starting point.
They do it as like,
you like a,
they are claiming a moral high ground
with this new position and they flaunt
it and it's like,
you know,
really annoying self satisfying kind of
in your face way.
It's,
it's defeatist for what they're trying
to say as well.
And I think that,
that uh,
yeah,
it's a very emotionally
recharge work.
Food in general as well be religious,
talking about food in general is
emotionally charged.
I mean just look at the twitter feed is
going to explode over this and that's
your barometer of that.
But you know,
it's,
it's right up there with religion and
politics.
It really is.
And when you say Vegan,
it immediately,
you know,
people snap into a preconceived idea of
what that is and what that means.
And they have a visual image of a person
in their mind,
you know,
it's a guy with dreadlocks kicking a
hacky sack up in Humboldt.
Always blowing a guy.
Yeah,
I mean,
whatever it is,
somebody has that imagery.
So the,
so that word,
you know,
and,
and people have different reasons for
getting into it,
you know,
you have the people who are into it for
the compassion and the saving the
animals.
That's a very different crowd and
attitude from the people that get into
it for health reasons or because they
don't want to have a heart attack or
whatever.
And uh,
and you know,
they both are I guess are technically
vegans but they're also,
you know,
very different.
And just because you choose to not eat
meat or whatever it doesn't,
does that mean that you're automatically
a democrat or what is your political
point of view and all of these things
get woven together and it.
And it makes it,
it makes it challenging to even talk
about it with an open mind.
Yeah.
It is a quite interesting situation and
there is the very real issue of the fact
that we are at the top of the food chain
and when you're at the top of the food
chain of bear,
some responsibility and you can,
you know,
we're the only animals that can really
decide and choose how to alter other
animals' lives,
like on purpose and figure out how to do
it.
And when you look at how we choose to do
it,
if you look at like food inc and you see
factory farming and stuff like that,
it really is a,
is a,
it's a damning statement about like
where we're at like spiritually,
like as a race,
like we're getting away with this really
heinous shit because we can because it's
easy to just not pay attention to it.
And that's uh,
that's,
that's the worst case scenario.
The best case scenario you would think
they have it set up.
So these animals live like they're on a,
an open prairie and they all just live a
natural life.
And then you call them from the herd and
you do it.
You do it,
you know,
easily.
So they live a natural life,
no different than any other cow in a
large environment where they get to roam
around and eat grass instead of being
forced fed corn and then you just kill
them.
I mean that's like the best case
scenario if you're going to eat cows.
But the way we do it is it's pretty
damning that human beings in the idea of
maximizing profit have decided to run
these ridiculous places where you're
packing pigs
right next to each other in these little
boxes and you,
you see the chickens all stuffed in
together with each other and pecking and
each other.
It's fucking gnarly,
man.
We,
yeah.
When you see food inc and you see the
chicken coop,
it's pretty tough.
It's pretty disturbing
connection because you know,
it's easy to go,
well chickens,
chickens,
the healthier option or whatever.
And then you see that it makes you,
it makes you think twice.
But I also think,
you know,
we've created this system that
ultimately is not sustainable.
I mean,
like an insane amount of our agriculture
goes to produce grain to feed these to
feed livestock like something like 90
percent or something like that.
It's crazy.
High,
crazy high.
And,
and you know,
with the,
and then it,
it,
you know,
brings up all the ecological arguments
about greenhouse gasses.
Oh,
they fill up a fucking storm.
Those goddamn animals ruined India.
Do you know they do.
They fucking,
they caused global warming.
No.
Bullshit and farting.
Yes.
Do it.
It's not bullshit.
It sounds silly,
but they fought so much.
You're dealing with in India,
you have so many fucking cows that they
really have pollution issues because of
cows farting in the air.
I heard the grass fed beef parks even
more.
Really.
I don't know where I wrote.
That's hilarious.
Well that makes sense because envy,
it would be much more grass fed.
Right.
And they're the ones who have the,
the big issue,
but they also have the issue in that
they don't kill cows or at least the
Hindus.
Do you?
Apparently Ken buy beef in India.
It's not uncommon.
It's just there's a huge group of them
that won't fuck with the cows.
Is that why they don't wear deodorant?
So it smells like deodorant or armpits
more than poop and Fart.
So you know,
it's like you're building your field.
Maybe your own body smell cancel out the
shit.
Smell in the air.
Yeah.
That's like way better than fucking
shit.
Yeah man.
That's like the worst case scenario is
like you're living around animals who
stink up the air constantly with their
fart gas and you can't kill them because
dog fart are fucking nasty.
Big Cow Farts.
That's way be sniffing our pits all day
long.
You're hungry and you know there's
people starving and they're just letting
these delicious cows just wander around
the fuck.
Did that ever happen?
I don't know.
I think it goes back to religion.
What a bunch of silly bitches they are
in India.
That is the one of the silliest choices
ever.
What do you want to do?
You want to starve to death or what you
eat these fucking delicious cows.
Let's just sit around some other farts
and complain and have more people's
cultural mores though.
I mean,
there are,
there are cultures that think that we're
insane for having dogs in our houses.
It's true.
Yeah.
It's interesting how,
um,
we just sort of adopt a pattern of
behavior based on our surroundings and
what's existed in that area for the
Indians,
I guess what it is the cow is sacred and
the Hindu culture.
So it is God or something like that or
relatives come back to life or
something.
Yeah.
Well,
when I worked at an Indian company,
I had a steering wheel.
My,
me and my ex girlfriend used to share a
cart and her steering wheel cover.
It was a cow,
a
print and they saw me drive up tonight
and I had a meeting and they told me to
please remove that from their steering
wheel because uh,
they,
they respect cows.
Why real Indian company was called the
software people.
Oh Wow.
Well you showed up with like murdered
scanning vote piece.
So just filled with,
you know,
just be nice and God's got to be a weird
thing.
What a strange thing to just choose to
really worship and lock onto it just
shows you.
I mean that's what they did in India,
you know,
he someplace else.
It was Buddha someplace else.
It was Jesus.
It's were so fascinating when it comes
to that.
Human beings are really,
really bizarre animals.
So your,
your story was that you were an athlete
and then you got unhealthy and then you
had a little bit of a health scare.
So that's when you decided to go vegan.
Yeah.
So I did.
So I did that juice cleanse and then you
know,
by the,
by the fifth day of that,
I just felt unbelievable,
you know,
like my energy level was through the
roof and all I had been doing it was
drinking like fruit and vegetable juice
and drinking this like beet root broth
and some teas and stuff like that.
And,
and it was,
it was amazing because I had,
I had abused my body for so long with
terrible food and terrible lifestyle and
I'm also a recovering alcoholic.
So I used to drink like a shitload.
You hit it on both ends.
Yeah,
I was hitting,
I was hitting it hard,
like I just,
you know,
I did not treat myself well and the idea
that like within five days I could feel
that good.
Like I didn't know that I could feel
that good or I hadn't felt that good in
15,
20 years.
It's pretty amazing.
The body is incredibly resilient,
you know,
when you treat it right.
So when I was done with that I thought
well,
what am I going to do?
You know,
like I want to,
I want to keep feeling this good like,
but I don't know,
I don't know what to do next.
And you know,
again,
I wish I'd gone out and read a bunch of
books or something,
but I just thought,
uh,
maybe I'll try a vegetarian diet.
Like I didn't do any education or
research,
but I just,
it just seemed like,
well that sounds,
you know,
healthy or healthier than what I'm
doing.
But kind of coming from an addiction
perspective and a recovery perspective.
Like I went to rehab 14 years ago and so
a lot of like the way,
like I sort of rewired my brain and the
way I think is kind of in the context of
addiction and recovery.
It just seemed like something I could
wrap my brain around because you're
either eating meat or you're not,
you know,
it's very,
it's very black and white just like
you're using drugs and you're drinking
or you're not,
you know,
you're either sober or you're using,
you know.
And so that made more sense to me then
hey I'm going to eat better.
Like I'm just going to eat healthy and
go to the gym because it's so vague,
you know,
like I don't know what that means,
maybe I would for like a week or two,
but I would definitely fall back into my
regular old behavior patterns.
So.
So I started doing that but it wasn't
long before,
you know,
I'm looking for the loopholes or
whatever because you can eat like shit
on a vegetarian diet.
You can eat like shit on a Vegan Diet.
So you know,
I could,
I could eat pizza hut cheese pizza and
get Nachos in,
you know,
eat McDonald's French fries and I'm a
vegetarian,
right.
So certainly,
you know,
that wasn't working,
but I did that for like six months and
of course I didn't lose any weight about
50 pounds heavier than I have now and
you know,
it was kind of back on the couch and
lethargic and I was ready to just bag
it.
But I thought,
you know,
I wonder what would happen if I just
kind of went that extra step and got rid
of the dairy and cut out the processed
foods and I didn't really think it would
make a difference.
Like I almost did it to prove that it
wouldn't or to like,
you know,
proven my wife that it wouldn't work,
so I could kind of keep doing what I was
doing and,
and,
and feel free about it.
But.
So I tried that and within a week,
like I was back to that energy level
that I felt when I did the cleanse,
like my energy level was through the
roof.
Like it was so high that I could only
sleep like a couple hours a night and I
was like bouncing off the walls and it
really did.
It did,
it made a huge debt.
It made a huge difference.
And I think getting rid of the dairy
made a much bigger,
like not eating the meat wasn't that
hard for me,
but getting rid of the dairy in my diet,
that was a lot harder.
That was almost like another detox
because dairies in so many foods so.
And I crave it man,
you know,
I love it.
So it was very difficult to kind of
break that.
Do you have cheat days?
I don't have cheat days.
So your,
your attitude is essentially the same
attitude that you have about like
recovery because.
Well that's the thing like I know
you know like Tim Ferris is big on the
cheat day with his slow car up and all
of that and it seems to work for a lot
of people and it makes sense for me.
Like for me it's about,
it goes back to like the addiction model
because I do crave this stuff man.
And I know if I had a cheeseburger like
once a week,
like I'd start eating cheeseburgers all
the time because it would,
you know,
you break the cycle and now I don't
think about it that much.
Like every once in a while I'll smell it
and it smells good to me,
but I don't go around like creating it
all the time.
But if I was to have it every once in
awhile then you're kind of,
you keep your,
you're still kinda like fertilizing that
little seed.
I respect that.
Anthony Bourdain loves pork so much.
He loves pork so much that they gave him
the option of quit eating pork or take
medicine to lower your blood pressure
and your cholesterol rather.
And he took the medicine so they'll take
the fucking medicine.
I need pork.
Talked about it on the show,
like being addicted to food.
And for him it's work.
Fatty pork.
He's willing to sacrifice health because
he likes to eat pork.
I mean that's,
that's pretty heavy man.
Fucking intense.
Yeah.
And I don't know how good that anti
cholesterol medication is for you.
Is that okay for you?
I mean,
you know,
there's a lot,
there's,
there's plenty of side effects from
that.
I mean,
uh,
I would imagine there are a crazy number
of people that are on these drugs and
it's amazing the extent to which the,
the,
the healthcare system,
you know,
the doctors just,
they just need your prescribed this
stuff and they're not that educated
about nutrition,
whether it's Paleo or Vegan or whatever.
It's not really part of the medical
school curriculum.
I'm shocked talking to doctors about
nutrition.
I've been shocked to having
conversations.
Right?
Very few are.
And it's not their fault.
Like,
you know,
they're studying all sorts of stuff and
maybe there's an elective here or there
like one required course that they have
to take,
but they're not really that school.
And in our system where we're sort of
grown and raised to believe that,
you know,
doctor knows best and you go to the
doctor and the doctor knows everything
and it's kind of alarming and eyeopening
to realize that that's not necessarily
the case.
At least with respect to nutrition,
there should most certainly be a,
uh,
a doctor of nutrition that you go to,
a doctor who is a,
a,
a full fledge Dr at the top of,
you know,
all the information that's available
today.
He's on top of all of it and his job is
just to check your blood and,
and give you a detailed writeup of
what's wrong with you nutritionally.
You know what?
So you don't have any [inaudible] in
your body.
You don't have this in your body,
you don't have,
you're missing nice.
And you know what,
whatever it is that he could show you
what your optimum levels of your various
nutrients should be.
Very,
very,
very few people you know,
ever get that done.
No.
And they do exist.
But that should be part of your
physical.
Yeah,
it shouldn't be.
It should be a regular thing because
for,
you know,
I talk about on the show all the time,
how much it changed me when I,
when I started drinking Kale shakes in
the morning and I'm not Vegan.
I still a,
I drink milk,
I still eat meat,
but in a massively increasing the amount
of plant nutrients I get into my body
and especially it seems like starting my
day with them that I,
I usually I don't eat like right when I
wake up I like to exercise sometimes or
just get up and do some stuff and then
I'll eat.
And uh,
my first meal is always really light.
It's always either some sort of a hemp
protein shake or it's this,
um,
this a Kale shake thing that I have.
But the difference is the Kale shake
gives me this fucking steady energy.
Like I can feel my body responding to
the nutrients.
Like you can literally feel it and
there's no.
The only negative about it at all is
that you have to ship more,
but that's just like cleaning out your
pipes and you actually look forward to
it because they're there are wonderful.
These poops or like a ride,
like you can feel it,
you can feel it in the way that you
know,
like when you have that First Cup of
coffee and you can feel your spine
getting tickled by the caffeine.
It's a similar.
It's a similar thing.
I mean,
it jacks you up.
I could not live without the vitamix.
I mean that's an amazing creation.
We got to town,
we bring it with.
We'd like travel with it.
You're an animal which
are part of your life.
I mean,
it's amazing.
It's a heavy thing because it's
expensive.
Right?
And things like 500 bucks,
450 bucks or whatever.
It's a.
it's a tough pill to swallow for a lot
of people to tell them they ought to get
one,
but it's a motherfucker.
Once you have it,
you're right.
I can't imagine not having it.
It's a motherfucker.
It's a beast.
That thing's amazing.
It's such a great thing to stuff
everything in there and plunge it and
then just turn that bitch on.
Okay.
I,
uh,
blended in avocado pit wants,
drank it.
Whoa.
What was that?
While I had a bunch of other stuff.
Is that good for you?
But just wanted to see if I could do it.
That's how the condo.
Even the pip,
but that's what I'm talking about.
Isn't that the poison that's got like a
night traits in it or something crazy
like.
No,
it has,
it has a front back to the future.
It's fucking nuclear.
It's like those sneakers that light up
when you step on them so that stuff.
I wouldn't,
I wouldn't recommend doing it all the
time.
I just wanted to see that.
The point is that I couldn't believe
that it was so powerful that it could
get actually blend that into.
For folks who don't know what a vitamix
is,
it's essentially a really high powered
blender that's designed to make like
vegetable smoothies,
but it also has like a top with a hole
in it and you have like a plunger and
the plunger drops down to like right
above the blade.
So it shoves everything into the blades
and matches.
It's incredible.
It never breaks the fucking thing.
Oh,
indestructible.
It's like a World War II relic kind of
thing.
Even the design of it looks like it's
been around forever.
Have you?
Um,
I think I tweeted you this.
Did you,
have you tried putting beets in there?
No,
no,
I have.
My recipe is so fucking good.
I don't want to mess with it too much.
I meshed with it by chain beat stuff.
Sound good.
But I changed the pairs to a pineapple,
put like a half of Eden and the Beet
Greens because the,
the,
the nitrites nitrites and nitrates.
I always get that wrong or whatever.
It's been shown to have significant
impact on,
uh,
the efficiency of your oxygen
utilization.
Like it really,
it's,
it's an,
it's a pretty significant like energy
booster.
Wow,
okay.
So the Greens as well,
but the Greens in and then it'll turn
everything read like even if you put a
tiny amount of bed and the whole shake
will be read and it's,
you know,
you want to put some other stuff in
there because it has kind of a heavy
taste but,
but you'll notice a difference.
Oh,
right.
Definitely.
I would definitely do that.
I'll try that shit tonight.
The same way that um,
the quarter's eps work because you know,
the quarter steps are so good at
boosting your oxygen uptake and the
efficiency of your oxygen utilization as
a similar effect.
I mean the quarter steps are crazy.
Awesome,
amazing.
You know?
Yeah.
Well that's what the main ingredient of
shroom tech sport is.
I take four of those before Jujitsu
glass and even if I'm,
you know,
I haven't been training recently like,
so it's amazing how much more energy you
have to make significant feeling of like
an extra little boost that you have.
It's like you've
been training at altitude and then you
come down to sea level like you feel
like you don't get winded,
you don't go into the same way,
that's for sure.
And people who have gone to altitudes
like you've had to change attitudes
rapidly,
like move up to boulder,
like real quick and that normally would
have issues with that.
They've found that if they take
cordyceps mushrooms it can can settle
them in,
settle them in quicker because for a lot
of people that altitude sickness is no
fucking joke.
I read this thing about babies being
born in Colorado that like a record
number of babies are born prematurely
like uh,
in Colorado because the,
the high altitude,
but it totally makes sense.
That's a harder way to live.
The whole thing is tougher.
Oxygen Utilization is fucking
everything,
man.
It's everything.
It's everything and it's in beats.
Beats Man.
Check it out.
She got some rhubarb while you're at it,
Joe also.
So you don't,
you do you miss meat at all?
Do you miss the smell?
Like if you have a neighbor who's
barbecuing and you had nightmares about
Fogo de Chao.
Oh,
I'm a human being,
man,
you know,
like I,
I ate that stuff for a long time.
I like it.
I like the smell of it.
I mean there are certain you can people
that will say discuss them or whatever
and that's,
you know,
I'm sure it does or whatever.
But for me I smell it.
It smell.
That's my problem.
Smells good.
I drive by Jack in the box.
I think that smells good and it's.
Yeah,
see that's,
that's like my problem.
That's why I can't have a cheat day for
me.
I understand.
So how did you get involved in endurance
athletics?
What happened there?
It was another kind of weird,
like organic thing that just evolved
over time.
I mean when I,
when I got on the plant based Diet,
I started exercising again,
you know,
mainly because I just had all this
energy I had to burn off.
Like I didn't,
I didn't have any designs on going back
to being an athlete or being competitive
in anything.
I just wanted to lose a little weight
and I want it to be able to enjoy my
kids at their energy level,
you know,
I have four kids now,
so it was really just about,
you know,
connecting with that part of myself that
I kind of lost touch with,
but nothing crazy,
you know,
I would go to the pool and swim a couple
times a week and you know,
do a light jog here and there.
My wife bought me a bike for my
birthday.
I'd never really ridden a bike before
and this was when I turned 40,
but then I had like a inexperience after
I'd been doing this for maybe four
months or something like that.
It's really moderate exercise.
I went out for a morning run out at,
uh,
you know,
where a mulholland drive,
the dirt road part of it that dumps out
at the bottom of Topanga on the valley
side.
So there,
there's a trail that you can,
you can literally go like all the way to
Brentwood,
right?
Goes forever.
And I just went out there one morning on
a weekday for a morning run and just,
you know,
you have those days and I'm sure you
have it in Jujitsu where you just feel
unstoppable.
Like you can just keep going forever.
I just started running and I just felt
amazing,
you know,
and I just kept going and going and say
I don't have to be back,
you know,
I'm going to keep going,
going.
I ended up running like the better part
of a marathon,
you know,
like I think 24 miles or something like
that,
that morning,
excuse me.
And I got back and I was like,
what is going on?
Some forest gumption.
Yeah,
it was,
it was okay.
I mean I'd never been a runner,
you know,
it's not like I had a background in
running or had any proficiency in it
really.
And it wasn't like I was going fast that
day either,
but it was just the idea that I could
keep going and I thought something's
going on here,
you know?
I don't know whether it's the nutrition
change or I've just unlocked some
dormant gene inside me.
But,
you know,
this felt good,
and then I was like,
I'd like to challenge myself and then I
started looking for something to do and
you know,
when you're 40 it's like,
a bucket list item or what's the midlife
crisis thing you want to do?
And started thinking about doing an
ironman because that's pretty typical
goal for a 40 year old guy who wants to,
you know,
conquer a mountain or whatever.
And uh,
and started trading a little bit more
and more.
And I didn't know anything about
triathlon.
I didn't know anything about ironman or
anything like that.
But I figured it seems like there's,
those ironman races are like every
weekend somewhere,
like tons of people are doing it.
It can't be that hard to get in one.
I'll just pick a city and you know,
a ways out and trained for it.
Myself and I went on the website one day
and realize that,
that uh,
they all sell out like a year ahead of
time.
Like they're like youtube tickets like
the,
after the day,
after one of those races the next day.
And they just sell out like in a couple
of hours.
So I couldn't get into any of those.
And,
and,
uh,
it was like,
well,
you know,
what am I going to do?
And nothing seemed to excite me and I
kind of lost my Mojo for a little bit.
But,
uh,
I was at Jamba juice one morning,
like maybe a month after that experience
getting a juice and you know,
how they have those,
um,
like competitor magazines that you see
in like running shoe stores or whatever,
like running shoe reviews or whatever.
Just laying around.
And I picked it up and started looking
at it.
And there was an article about this dude
named,
uh,
David Goggins,
who is this bad ass navy seal guy.
Like guy had been like a football player
and a power lifter.
Like big strapping guy.
I think he was up.
He had weighed like 275 pounds at one
point and had seen some shit,
you know,
as a,
as a navy seal.
And had lost a lot of friends in
inaction.
And he decided that he was going to go.
He was going to find the 10 most
difficult endurance races in the world
and do them all to raise money for.
It wasn't the wounded warriors
foundation,
but it was something like that,
like a,
you know,
so that he could raise money for the
families of these,
these friends of his that had fallen and
he had.
He had just done this race called
Badwater,
which is 135 mile run through death
valley that goes up like Mount Whitney
at the end like this and it's like crazy
hot,
like 110,
120 degrees out in the desert and he had
just done really well in that and he had
never really done much endurance sports
before that.
Like you literally had fallen into it
and he had just put in an incredible
performance.
And then like a month later he did this
race called ultra man,
which is this insane double ironman
distance race in Hawaii where over the
course of three days you circumnavigate
the entire big island of Hawaii,
which is like a big island.
It's like the size of Connecticut.
Right?
So I was reading about this and it just
seemed like such a cool event.
Like it.
Not only was it longer than iron man,
which I didn't think was possible.
Um,
it was a broken up into stages.
So the first day is six point two mile
ocean swim followed by a 90 mile bike
and the last part,
the last 20 miles of that bike,
you go up to volcano national park.
So it's like a 40,000
foot gain and the second day you ride
170 miles around the eastern side of the
island,
like up through Hilo and you end up in
this little town called Havi.
On the third day you run 52 point four
miles,
double marathon from Havi back into Kona
where the race started.
And I was like,
what is this?
And it was cool because they limited it
to just 35,
like invitation only competitors like
you had to apply to get into this race.
They don't close any of the roads and it
was almost like this family affair.
We have to bring your own crew and they
kind of take care of you.
And feed you out of a van while you're
doing this race and the crews kind of
help each other out and the competitors
help each other out.
So it's a race,
but it,
it seemed almost like this crazy
spiritual odyssey,
you know,
like this experiment in expansion,
much more than a race.
And I was like,
that was what I was looking for,
you know,
it wasn't like I was looking for a race
to go see how fast I could go or how
many guys I could be like it resonated
with me because it seemed more like an
opportunity to learn more about myself
in a way that was unique.
You know what I mean?
Like it was a like this crazy down the
rabbit hole,
like spiritual adventure.
And so it just captivated me and I,
I was like,
it was one of those things where,
you know,
when you come across something and
something just clicks inside you and you
know,
like that's the direction you're
supposed to go in or you're on the right
path.
Or,
you know,
maybe you've had that in stand up or at
some point in your life where you just
feel like you're directed in a certain
way,
you know,
where everything just kind of seems in
alignment.
It was like,
I just knew I wasn't going to do that
race.
Like I just,
I didn't know how and I hadn't done
anything of note to Merritt getting into
it or anything like that.
But I was like,
I'm going to find a way to do that.
Like I've got to do that and I couldn't
stop thinking about it.
And I ended up calling up the,
a race director and it was some months
before you could even send in your
application because I was like,
I couldn't stop thinking about it and I
needed to like just if she going to tell
me like there's no way I was getting in,
then I could at least put that to bed.
So I just call her up and said,
you know,
I read about this race and I can't stop
thinking about it and I'd really like to
do it,
but,
you know,
maybe I'm crazy because,
I don't know why I'm even calling you
because I haven't really done very much.
Um,
you know,
and she said,
well,
what have you done?
And I was like,
done anything barely,
barely,
you know,
I'm just getting back into being fit
again.
And she had every reason to just say,
well,
you know,
why don't you call me in a couple of
years and,
you know,
we'll see what you've done that and
maybe I'll let you into this race.
But she was like,
well,
listen,
you know,
it means a lot that you called early and
uh,
why don't you just touch base with me in
a couple of months and we'll evaluate
your training and we'll go from there.
So she kinda like left the cracking the
door open,
you know?
So it was enough to like give me a
little bit of hope.
Like the pilot light was lit a little
bit and I was like,
I'm going to get into that race,
you know,
I'm going to find a way to get into that
race.
And I hired a coach and I started
training as if I was already in.
This was back in early 2008 and uh,
I mean it's a long story,
but ultimately she ended up relenting
and letting me in and I ended up doing
that race in 2008 and I hadn't done an
ironman before that.
I tried to do a half ironman the year
before and I didn't even finish.
So,
you know,
I wasn't going in with some crazy like
endurance pedigree.
So it was,
it was,
it was a cool experience though.
And I ended up doing pretty well in that
race.
How well did you do?
I got 11th that year.
Wow.
That's amazing.
It's crazy.
You couldn't finish and then a year
later you get 11th,
11th in 2008.
And then [inaudible] at that time really
like,
we were like,
yeah,
bad news bears.
Like I had no idea what I was doing.
Like my dad came out to like help me
crew and a couple buddies from out here
and none of us knew anything about
anything and I just wanted to finish,
you know,
and I just wanted to like not die.
So I,
I approached it like very
conservatively,
but I ended up exceeding my
expectations.
So I thought I wonder what would happen
if I spent a year like preparing to go
back and actually race it,
you know,
rather than just trying to finish and
kind of being timid about it.
So for 2009 I trained my ass off and I
went back and uh,
and I ended up getting out.
I got out of the swim with a 10 minute
lead on the next guy and then I held
that lead for the rest of that day
through that 90 mile bike.
So I finished the first day with a 10
minute lead on,
on the field.
Ten minutes?
Yeah.
Hugely going into detail.
But that was a race car though.
Ridiculous.
He must have thought I was crazy because
I didn't see anyone else all day,
you know,
like as I was out in front
and uh,
my wife and my kids were crewing me
actually,
so I was having to kind of like tell
them what to do.
And they were great but it wasn't like
they had experienced
anything like this,
which made me very nervous.
So what is a crew person that I do well
there in,
each competitor has to bring a van and
that van is filled with like all your
shit man.
So you gotta have all your food that
you're gonna eat,
like while you're racing and then,
and then afterwards,
you
know,
ice for ice baths afterwards and they're
filling your bottles and feeding them,
feeding,
bu they kind of leapfrog you in park and
then you do bottle handoff.
So you always have nutrition on the bike
and uh,
and they keep you,
make sure you don't take any wrong.
Turns like they,
they're in charge of navigating and
just,
you know,
and if you have anything mechanically
goes wrong with your bike or whatever,
extra parts.
So,
and it's filled with all your clothes
because you're going around the island,
you're not going back to where you
started that day.
You're going to stay in a different
place each night,
so you have to have all your stuff with
you.
So these vans are like packed from
Florida ceiling with stuff.
Wow.
I would've never thought that much
involved in racing.
Yeah.
Logistically it's very,
it's,
there's a lot that goes into it to pull
it off and everything.
Now is there,
does everybody know how to apply
nutrition to these races?
Is it like a consensus or do some people
try to do them without eating?
There's no way you can do it without
eating.
I mean you got along the way.
You got to be taking in.
I mean the consensus is you got to take
in about two to 300 calories an hour and
everybody's stomachs different and the
intensity with which you're,
you're going will depend upon how well
you can digest the food.
Like if you're on the rivet and going
hard,
it's gonna be harder to digest calories
and the kind of calories become more
important because you can't,
you're not gonna be able to eat solid
food if you're hammering,
you know what I mean?
What do you,
what do you eat,
do eat fruits.
So I eat what I eat is probably
different than,
than certain other.
Everybody has their own thing.
Um,
I like to stay away from the shirt,
like a lot of endurance athletes run or
whatever,
you know,
usually kind of Gatorade,
econ of stuff like cytomax and the,
that kind of stuff,
that real high sugar stuff.
But when you're going all day,
like you're going to be out on a
racecourse for eight or nine hours and
then you've got to do it the next day.
Your,
your system can't handle that.
So I try to eat a more like a lower
glycaemic higher carbohydrate,
a fuel source.
So they have this stuff called par carbo
pro or something called perpetuum.
They're like Maltodextrin powders.
So it's,
it's a like a low-glycemic kind of
carpet,
complex carbohydrate fuel source.
And you can put like 900 calories in one
bottle and you can kind of sip off that.
It's like pancake batter,
taste terrible.
But I'll eat,
I'll eat bananas.
I'll put like a lightly baked.
Yams are good.
Dates are good.
And then how come only lightly baked.
Um,
because if they're overcooked that like
fries,
a lot of the nutrition out of them.
But you want a soft enough like there's,
they're almost like you can squeeze them
into your mouth,
are easy to digest when you're riding a
bike,
you know?
And they have most of the nutrition in
them.
Yeah.
They're great for nutrition.
Sorry,
what is it the kills in determining if
it breaks down the tissue like that?
How come it doesn't kill the nutrition
of it makes it all soft and mushy?
Well you just don't.
If you,
if you,
if you like completely fry it and
overcook it,
then it becomes like a dead thing.
Right?
Do they know exactly what temperature it
down?
Yeah,
I mean somebody probably does so don't.
I've always wondered about like cooking,
like
killing vitamins,
like at when,
like they say if you lightly sauteed,
you're okay.
Like,
are you sure you know?
At what level does it,
is it really that bad to eat them raw
that we have to fucking jazz everything
up with,
with fire and hot metal?
Yeah,
I know.
Well,
we're the only animals that cook our
food,
right?
We're also the only animals with tvs are
the only animals that drive cars were
the only owls that talk to each other.
Disagree with how good shit tastes when
you cook it.
We talked to each other dude,
fucking shit.
Taste good.
When he could have hit that is the
problem.
It does taste better.
Like,
like um,
you know,
there's even vegetable dishes that are
absolutely delicious because they're
cooked,
you know,
but that's just not as good for your
body.
Well,
I don't know.
It seems like there's differing schools
of thought on that.
I mean,
I think that,
you know,
you have the really hardcore raw is they
would just eat everything raw and
certainly I think it's,
it's,
it's great to eat lots of raw foods.
You know what I mean,
like the raw foods you put in your,
in your vitamix or whatever,
and I eat a lot of raw foods,
but I still eat cooked foods,
you know,
I got,
I got to have me a little cook food just
for the,
like the feeling of it.
Right.
Comfort food.
No.
Do you eat pastas at all?
I'll eat brown rice.
Pasta,
like the gluten free kind.
The cql u of M is eat Kale.
Zucchini bread too.
Yeah.
I mean I try not to overdo it on the
pasta.
I'm usually have more like brown rice
stuff instead.
Brown rice,
steamed veggies,
sauteed and top it off with the Coca
Cola or perhaps a Pepsi Cola.
Red Bull.
Do you take any caffeine?
What do,
what are you thoughts on that?
I've gone back and forth on caffeine.
I've,
I've gone periods without it and then
I've used it as well.
Um,
I think that,
uh,
you know,
when you're using it compulsively and
addictively it's not a good thing and
fries your adrenals and makes you tired
ultimately.
Um,
I think a cup of coffee in the morning
is not the worst thing is particularly
for an athlete.
I mean it's definitely a performance
enhancer,
like if I'm going out for a long bike
ride,
you know,
a nice little strong cup of coffee
before my ride.
Definitely I can definitely feel the
difference.
But yeah,
I think it,
you know,
you can't be just hammering coffee all
day long.
I like a Nice Cup of coffee before a
podcast and a Nice Cup of coffee before
Jujitsu,
like to get a little bit.
It's really a crutch.
It is,
it is this week,
but I've gone periods when I,
when I don't drink coffee at all and I
feel fine and you know,
mental lapse back into drinking it from
time to time.
Well I,
uh,
during periods of heavy writing,
I will drink a lot of fucking coughing
and uh,
I had one day where I was working on
this,
this piece and I was up til like 5:00
in the morning just just wired with
coffee and then the next day I tried no
coffee and boy was that a trip?
Like I had a headache all day,
like my body was like,
dude,
let's just a cup of coffee.
Let's just feed the demon.
The demon given a little.
It's like I was like,
I got to be careful.
Like this is how you get addicted to
powerful drug.
And I was setting,
I was setting the stage for addiction.
I was like also I had a headache.
Like I didn't,
I didn't want to not have the caffeine,
you know,
so just was taking too much and it was
over a course of a few days where I was
like really hitting it hard writing.
You have to be careful because fucking I
had headaches,
I had withdrawals,
but I found that a really strenuous
exercise.
Like if I have anything wrong with me,
if I have a jet lag,
if I'm a little out of it from landing
somewhere and I can't shake the cobwebs
loose,
just really intense,
strenuous exercise just seems to reset
the whole thing.
Snaps.
You wrote back snaps you right back.
I really,
I really feel bad for people who don't
exercise,
who tried to travel a lot because I hear
people tell me that they're fucked up
for like two weeks and they're like,
that's crazy.
I've been traveling
a lot lately and that's the only thing
I,
I don't sleep great.
And hotel rooms and just,
you know,
that first night in a new environment or
whatever,
it's always a little off and you know,
the first thing when I get there just
I've got to work out or whatever.
It's,
it's exactly what it is.
You got to wipe the slate clean and then
it just,
it really helps with the jet lag and the
sleep and acclimating and everything.
Yeah.
It's.
And it's one of those things we just got
to start it,
just get it going and then once you get
it going,
it's sort of takes care of itself and
you're in the middle of it.
It feels great,
but it's like that first step of doing
that first squat during that first
anything.
It's like,
oh,
come on now,
but if you can overcome that,
it gives you that feeling like,
like lately I've got a lot of shit done
that I wanted to get done and I got this
great feeling because of that,
you know,
it's got a lot like momentum,
whenever I feel like that I'm
accomplishing things that I wanted to do
and you know,
do like a I,
you know,
I set out to do x today and I got it all
done.
It's like,
yes.
I'm like,
the next day I feel like a little more
charged up.
I feel like I've gotten,
well look,
I'm doing what I'm trying to get done.
I'm getting it done.
I'm feeling great about it.
And a lot of people I think don't have
that.
They don't build that momentum enough in
their life.
They don't know.
Pick a few goals,
lock onto them,
go with it,
and then let it build up to something
else.
Let it build up to more,
let it build up to the next thing.
And also I think that there's this weird
thing
equation with exercise because it's so
easy to say you don't have time or busy
or whatever and you know,
I go through that a lot and,
and,
and it's easy to justify not doing it,
but ultimately when I just quiet that
thought and do it anyway,
I ended up getting more done and
everything that I needed to get done
ends up getting done.
And if I don't do it,
I ended up wasting time and I'm less
productive and I'm not thinking clearly.
And there's a lot of like down wasted
time.
I think everybody has a different sort
of biology and uh,
I know,
I know this for sure.
People have different needs so I don't
say that everybody needs it,
you know,
I mean I think it benefits,
but I don't know that everybody needs
it,
but I certainly know that I need it when
I don't have it.
It makes a big difference.
I don't like the way I feel.
I don't like to.
I don't like getting annoyed at things
too easily.
I don't like this weird testosterone
buildup that happens after a few days of
not exploding on something,
you know,
it's like my body's become most
certainly addicted to that release and
it knows that it can navigate social
water's better when it's just totally
drained of all the Monkey Dna,
you know,
if I don't get that out at the gym,
I don't feel like I'm as nice a person.
I don't feel like I'm as balanced.
My wife will just kick me out of the
house.
He needed to go ride your bike or do
something.
Don't come back until you do.
I have a,
a crazy gym in my house.
It's in the garage.
Like half of the garage was done for a
company called Garage Mahal.
Wow.
So my garage has set up.
It's got mats.
I've got a grappling dummy that I
strangle.
I like to Jujitsu on a dummy and I have
a kickboxing bags and ropes to climb so
I never have to go anywhere.
It's always right there.
So there.
That cuts out a lot of the fucking
bullshit and procrastination with a 20
minute ride to the gym.
And then I only have 40 minutes to work
out because if I just took a nap right
now,
maybe I would perform better tonight and
they can just do some working out at
home tonight.
I haven't been in my house.
For me,
it's huge.
The ability to just go outside.
And even when I was broke,
I always had a heavy bag,
you know,
tied something to the rafters in the
garage.
You know,
having something like that is to me
having just a place where you can lease,
release it's some way.
Know,
get that fucking blow out in some way.
So important for maximizing sanity.
I need it.
I don't know.
Some people,
some people don't need it.
I just sneezed a lot.
Yeah,
Brian's fine without it.
I'm telling you,
it's not even an angry guy.
Um,
I think,
uh,
it's,
it's a,
it's a great benefit to everybody.
People can get through life without that
benefit,
but just silly,
silly to do it.
That's what I tell him.
I'm like,
you're silly.
He got,
he got really skinny at one point in
time though.
Brian was like way fat at one point in
time and then he went crazy
weightwatchers and he shrunk down to
like a tiny man.
Strange.
Yeah.
Where are you at now?
Uh,
I'm about halfway back to what I used
to,
but now it's more just a.
I eat barely little,
like I eat only at like nine or 10:00
at night until I go to bed.
But it's not like I eat crazy bad.
It's more like I'll go home and eat lean
pockets in a salad or something and they
don't eat until nine at night.
You literally known any food all day and
it's mostly because of starbucks.
That's double shot.
He gets Trenta double shots,
which is basically cancer.
It's just cancer in a liquid form.
Go
all day,
all day.
And then you hit the lean pockets at and
it
out.
Yeah.
It's fucking super good for you.
You're on the right track.
So here's a,
here's a,
here's a video of me,
uh,
when you were super skinny,
super skinny,
you got really what,
what is the lightest you got?
You got below one 70,
right?
You don't think this mother fucker
doesn't want to hear about Rick Rolling
when you name is rich roll.
How annoying is that everyday,
man.
So fucking day.
That's so rude.
And it came out of nowhere too.
You lived most of your life without a,
without a rick roll.
And then all the sudden this one fucking
song.
The Internet is so bizarre.
The Bane of my existence,
you know,
it's funny too.
There's a,
uh,
you know,
this rapper Nipsey Hussle,
Nipsey Hussle and he has a song called
rich roll,
right?
So it's,
so,
it's,
it's all about the rich roll and the.
And so my twitter feed fills up with all
this crazy insanity from people re
tweeting the song that I guess it's a
pretty popular song.
And so I have to do,
you know,
like I'm getting confused with this guy.
You should embrace it.
You should go like the opposite of what
Rick Ross did.
You should do a music video,
you should claim the real rich roll son,
right?
You know,
and then maybe you can like hip hop
people into being vegans.
It's so close to being to,
to Rick Ross too,
so it's all confused.
It is,
right?
You know,
it's right there.
It's right next door.
Neighbors just by a lot of trench coats
or you'll be good.
Do you,
um,
fuck around with probiotics,
do you?
Um,
yeah,
a little bit.
Yeah.
There's some pretty good like plant
based ones.
I have this,
a nutrition guru,
my buddy compton rom,
he's got a name,
his name is Compton Rom.
You should actually playing on,
he would make an incredible guest like
blow your mind.
You can come watch videos of him on
Youtube.
You've talked about some crazy stuff
like that.
Just like the energy of food and he's
super into like he said,
he has a phd in microbiology and so he's
helped me a lot with like my nutrition
and spent a little bit of a mentor and
he's got a startup company called
ascended health and he's all about
trying to find the best superfoods all
over the world and provide them to uh,
to customers.
And he's traveling all the time.
He's going to like Thailand,
all these crazy places.
Trying to find places where he can grow
this stuff and so I would go to his
house and his house look like in his
kitchen.
It looked like a,
it looks like a giant meth labs.
It's got all these tubes everywhere and
all this crazy stuff.
He's like,
oh,
you gotta try this.
I just got this reservoir trollin from.
It's from the finest Bordeaux grapes,
Scans.
Stuff's amazing.
I'm gonna,
I'm going to make up A.
I'm going to make some powder for you.
And he's,
he's always trying to like help me with
my like training and racing nutrition by
giving me some of this crazy stuff.
And so his whole thing is,
um,
he's super knowledgeable about
probiotics and microbes because he
studied microbes and like,
um,
like the Gi tract microbial activity
forever and ever and knows more about it
than anyone I've ever met.
And it's fascinating because I talk a
little bit about this in my book too,
that we think we're,
you know,
we're made up of trillions of cells,
right?
And we think we're these sentient beings
and we have control over what we think
and our decisions.
And all of that,
but at the same time we have to realize
that we're,
we have like 10 times the number of our
cells and microbes in our gut alone,
like our microbial ecology in our Gi
tract has like,
you know,
10 times the number of microorganisms
compared to all of our cells in our
entire body and there's been these
studies that have come out and they're
starting to come out where they're
studying,
um,
the extent to which your microbial
ecology in your gut can trigger your
nervous system and actually impulse you
in a decision making way.
And they've discovered like links
between what kind of microbial ecology
do you have in your gut and the and the
foods that you crave.
So yeah.
Yeah.
And,
and,
and so like having like probiotics are
all about improving the health of your,
your flora in your gut.
Right?
And if you have healthy flora it,
it craves and feeds on healthy foods.
Right?
But if you go to Jack in the box every
day or you eat lean pockets every night,
then you're going to have,
you're gonna have like a different kind
of microbial ecology,
like the microbes that are in that food
starts to propagate in your gut and that
takes over and that becomes the ecology
and they're realizing that that ecology
then sends signals to your brain that
makes you crave more of those foods.
So it's that craving cycle that I was
talking about earlier.
It's so easy and it sounds insane.
But then I was thinking about that.
Um,
you saw,
remember I'm the documentary super size
me.
Yes.
So,
so Morgan spurlock,
when he first starts out,
remember he's like getting sick when
he's eating McDonald's.
Like you can't handle it.
Like he barfs out the window one day
when he's a couple of days in like
cannot manage.
He's like a can't imagine going back to
Mcdonald's.
He's only like three days in.
He's getting sick all the time.
And then fast forward like a couple days
later and he wakes up with headaches and
he's like creating the food and he and
his headaches won't go away until he
goes to Mcdonald's.
So it's like you can make the argument
that that could be attributable to a
change in his microbial ecology,
you know,
like now he's replaced as healthy
because I think his wife or his
girlfriend at the time,
it was like a Vegan chef.
He was eating really clean and then he
just starts eating this Mcdonald's and
he replaced is that microbial ecology
and his gut with the kind that feeds on
Mcdonald's and suddenly it's creating it
all.
Did you imagine if they found out that
Mcdonald's actually had implanted
microbial biology,
that they,
that they created in a lab that
specifically makes you want their shitty
cheeseburgers?
He just just fucking crave that
cheeseburger.
Oh,
Mcdonald's that
I.
I saw a thing online where it dude left
one out for six months and it never rot.
It saw that and I was like,
check please.
That's it.
I'm done no more.
It's only filet of fishes which are
nutritious and delicious.
And he let out that it was the burger
and the fries too.
Maybe even.
I saw that though.
I don't think the fries rod either.
It's fucking crazy.
It's a,
it's not food.
It's like it's just filler.
It's weird.
I mean it's like gut filler.
I mean you can live on it for short
periods of time.
It's better than starving to death,
man.
That stuff is fucking bad for you.
So
calm and it's everywhere.
And his numbers from that movie,
like just after 30 days,
it's doctor was like,
yeah,
this is bad.
Crazy bat.
And it took him like a couple of years
to like lose the weight and get back to
his baseline.
Did it really?
Yeah.
I mean it said it took them a really
long time.
Well that sounds like he's a lazy bitch.
Lost weight curriculum a couple of
years.
But I think if it wasn't just his
weight,
it was like as cholesterol levels and
all that kind of really.
Did he try to go Vegan after that?
Or heavy vegetable dye?
I don't know.
I mean,
I know his girlfriend who was a Vegan
chef,
so I would imagine he returned to
something along that lines,
but I don't know.
Well,
what do you think of when you hear guys
like Rob Wolf say eat bacon and eggs for
breakfast?
Well,
I mean the first thing I would say is
that,
you know,
have a lot of respect for rob.
I think rob,
great guy.
Yeah.
And I love the interview and you know,
Robin,
I have the same goal.
You know what I mean?
Like we're both working towards the same
thing which is trying to get people
healthier and more fit.
You know,
we differ on a couple subcategories of
that.
But like I think rob is,
is doing good stuff.
I mean I,
I definitely disagree when he says you
should eat bacon and eggs for breakfast
and I think that,
you know,
and I remember your reaction to that
even you were like surprised that that
was,
that I'd never heard.
I never heard.
I've never heard anyone say that myself.
I've never heard anyone say that Kale
shakes.
Like don't eat kale shakes.
You don't need.
Right.
So,
so
a lot about Paleo that I think is
fantastic,
you know,
they,
they issued dairy,
they shoe process foods and the oil that
they say is okay.
Is Olive oil in moderation?
Um,
you know,
we disagree.
It's a very,
like the idea is low carb,
right?
Like it's low carb,
high protein and I think that that works
really well for losing weight and maybe
works for some people in terms of energy
levels.
But my perspective on the whole thing is
I'm coming from looking at the
healthcare crisis in America where like
people are just keeling over with heart
attacks constantly.
You know what I mean?
Heart disease is rampant,
you know,
and people are getting diabetes like
crazy and you know,
even children are getting diabetes.
I mean when we were kids,
diabetes wasn't really a thing right
now.
Like diabetes is a huge thing.
Like obesity and obesity figures are
insane.
Like 40 percent
of Americans are going to be obese by
2014 and childhood obesity rates are
crazy and school lunches are terrible.
And,
and when I look at it like that,
like I think that,
um,
you know,
I can't get around the fact that when I
read the studies on plant based
nutrition,
you know,
when you read the China study or you
read Dr Russell Austin's book prevent
and reverse heart disease,
there's a pretty clear correlation
between getting rid of the meat and
dairy and eating a whole food,
plant based diet and your ability to
repair your body from these conditions
that are plaguing us unnecessarily.
I mean,
heart disease,
a foodborne illness,
you know,
you can not only prevent it,
you can actually reverse it.
And this,
this guy,
Dr Nelson,
have you ever heard of this guy?
Yes.
Okay.
So for maybe your listeners who don't
know,
he is a,
he's a bad ass.
First of all,
the guy was,
he's Yale educated in these Olympic gold
medalist in rowing and like 1968 and I
think it was a,
I think he's uh,
uh,
I think he was a Vietnam.
Uh,
I think he's a Vietnam veteran also.
I'm not sure about that.
But then he became a surgeon and he was,
uh,
you know,
the head surgeon at the Cleveland
Clinic,
which is if you have heart disease or
heart problems,
like that's where you want to go,
like those.
But Cleveland Clinic,
Cleveland Clinic,
yeah.
Those ones you're feeling like shit,
right.
Go to Cleveland.
He's,
yeah.
They know what's up there.
And like back in the seventies,
he started to realize that when he
treated his patients with,
uh,
with a plant based whole food diet,
that they were able to reverse their
heart disease without surgery.
And He,
and he was starting to look at the,
the um,
what are you?
I'm having a brain fart.
The uh,
what are those pictures of the heart
called the angiograms.
So you'd see these before and after
angiograms and you could clearly see,
you know,
the clogged arteries becoming clear
again and,
and,
and it working.
And that was not a popular thing like in
the 19 seventies,
in the 19 eighties.
And you know,
to a large degree,
it's still not popular,
but you know,
it didn't make him a popular surgeon
there because.
Well,
because they make money off of surgery,
you know,
and you're saying the putting that
information out that you can heal
yourself through vegetables was not
popular because they literally wanted
people to be sicker.
It's not that they will make money,
it's not.
It's not that they wanted people to be
sicker,
it's just that the system is set up,
you know,
the way that you profit is by performing
expensive surgery.
That is the way they profit,
but it's a big leap between that and
being upset at something that heals
people.
It's not,
it's not.
I don't think that it was that they were
upset.
It was that it was new and there wasn't
enough evidence at that time to fully
substantiate what he was doing and they
had their sort of,
this is what we do here and when
somebody comes in and they're in this
condition,
we prescribe this procedure and he was
saying,
I don't want to do that.
I want to do this like intensive diet
thing with them and counsel them and see
if I can avoid that.
And that was not.
That was not a popular option.
Okay.
That that makes
more sense.
So the,
uh,
essentially the,
the doctors had a very specific path
that they would follow when you had x
wrong with you and that that path
usually lead to some sort of surgery and
he was trying to avoid that with
festivals.
Yeah.
And I think that's still true today.
And we were talking about statens you go
in with high cholesterol or whatever
your doctor is,
most likely you're going to prescribe
you statens he may say,
you know,
change your diet or do this and then
you'll come back and,
and it doesn't change.
And then he'll say,
well,
it's genetic and you need to take this
medicine when in fact,
you know,
I,
I believe that it actually,
you can lower your cholesterol if you
change your diet properly,
but,
but the point getting back to Dr
Esselstyn is that,
you know,
he was sort of blazing this trail a long
time ago back when,
you know,
not too many people were listening and
it's taken many,
many years to kind of get traction with
this.
And it's taken,
you know,
the China study and,
and his book.
And the documentary forks over knives to
get people sort of paying attention and
listening now and now there's kind of
like an awareness that didn't exist
before and that the scientific studies
are,
are pretty compelling that when you,
you know,
you remove the animal proteins,
you remove the processed foods and you
remove the dairy that you can really
heal yourself.
And so if you,
um,
cut,
I mean it is what it has.
Has it been proven that that is the
order that works,
hasn't been proven that if you cut out
the dairy,
cut out the processed food,
cut out the meat specifically on
vegetable live,
off of vegetables,
vegetable nutrition,
that that is the only way to go.
Or have they done vegetable nutrition
and grass fed meat and natural meat?
Yeah.
There's plenty of studies out there.
And what do they show?
What are the differences between
that?
It's the,
the,
the actual animal protein is the,
is the activator of have a lot of the
congenital diseases really?
Yeah.
And what do they attribute that to?
Just even,
uh,
even game or is it fatty meats
even even game?
Well,
certainly the saturated fat doesn't
help,
but there's something about the animal
proteins themselves and in particular
the Casein,
which is the,
the,
the protein in the dairy that,
that proves problematic and what does it
do specifically to the human body?
That's a good question.
I have,
which I wish Dr Esselstyn was here to
answer that are starting to get a little
too technical.
I don't want,
I don't want to speak out of school or
say the wrong or or
so.
What they found though essentially was
that a lot of ailments are started and
in the activator for starting these
ailments and diseases is animals to see
eat animals,
you're going to get certain diseases
that you would avoid if you just ate
vegetables.
Right?
Right.
And the China study originated around
studying cultures where there really
wasn't any animal products or animal
proteins in their diet and looking at
the,
at the extent of cardiovascular disease.
So there was a certain,
um,
area in China where a,
it had a huge population of 260,000
people or something like that.
The incidence of heart disease was
almost zero.
Wow,
that's crazy.
And so here again,
this long epidemiological study where
they really took a hard look at it and
it's interesting.
It's really interesting.
That's incredible.
The number zero,
that's ridiculous.
I don't know if it was zero,
but it was close as you're always very,
very,
very low.
Do,
um,
that,
that's incredible.
What,
how do they make sure that they get the
proper amount of protein and the proper
amount of amino acids.
But from what I understand,
the real issue with the Vegan Diet is
you have to be really diligent about
the,
uh,
the proper proteins that you get because
I'm all the various pr,
like even Broccoli has protein in it,
but it doesn't have like a complete
protein like,
like say meat does,
but there's keenwah and hemp is a very
complete protein.
But how do you make sure that you get
the right amount?
Well,
I think there's a lot of misconceptions
about that and there's been a lot of
sort of deepened king of the complete
versus incomplete argument that gets
pretty technical.
But I think that if you're eating a well
rounded,
balanced plant based diet with lots of
different,
you know,
if you're essentially,
if you're eating grains,
legumes,
fruits and vegetables and all the
different colors and you know,
you're rotating them through or
whatever,
then you're not going to have a problem.
It's almost like nature is rigged.
It,
you're not going to have a protein
deficiency.
And you know,
just speaking from my own experience
with this,
when I first started on the Vegan Diet,
you know,
I was nervous about that.
I was scared about,
especially as I was starting to train
more and more and uh,
my cabinet was full of all kinds of
crazy supplements,
just tons.
And I was like just mounds and mounds of
plant based proteins in my shakes
because I was nervous that I was going
to injure myself or you know,
it was going to get sick or something
like that.
And over the last couple of years I've
slowly started weaning myself off of a
lot of that stuff where I use very,
very little now.
And I haven't noticed a difference in my
ability to one recover in between
workouts or build lean muscle mass or
endurance.
And my endurance is continuing to
improve.
So I do use,
you know,
I use hemp protein,
I love him protein.
Um,
I usually combine it with like pea
protein or,
or sprouted brown rice protein.
Wait,
what protein?
Protein.
I had some today in honor of this
podcast that's different from urine
therapy.
Yeah.
Ps,
man,
it's very high in protein.
So what is the fucking do it?
I don't know.
I don't even do it every day.
Like I only do it when I'm training
really hard or I feel like,
you know what,
I'm not gonna,
you know,
I don't have any lines,
holes in the house or something like
that.
I'm always trying to source my proteins
from whole foods.
So the misconception is that you gotta,
you gotta eat tons and tons of protein
and you can only get,
you know,
real good protein quality protein from
animal products.
Like I just don't believe that to be
true.
You remember when that dude wasn't
Travis Barker got into a,
a
plane crash.
And he got burned and he needed a
drummer.
Yes.
He needed a,
um,
a skin graft and when he had a skin
graft,
his body was not healing until he
started eating meat again.
And we started eating meat again.
It started healing rapidly.
Interesting.
He said that was a,
he was a vegan before that,
but he had to stop being a Vegan.
I'm pretty sure.
I don't want to paraphrase this guy's
story,
but,
uh,
I'm pretty sure that is a,
how he said it.
Is there any possible benefit in your
eyes to eating animal protein for as far
as performance,
physical performance as far as a mean
even though it may be the catalyst to a,
triggering certain ailments in certain
individuals and that can be documented.
Is it also possible that there's a
benefit to it too?
And from a performance perspective?
Yes.
It's certainly,
it's certainly possible.
I don't know.
Especially in the fast twitch sports.
Yeah.
I mean,
you know,
what I do is so long it's a very
specific kind of sport that's very
different from Jujitsu or sprint running
or anything like that.
But there are plenty of athletes out
there in various disciplines that seem
to be,
that seemed to be doing well,
but,
you know,
has there been a double blind,
sort of case study on the difference.
I don't know the answer to that.
Um,
and I think that,
that,
uh,
you know,
for me,
it goes back to um,
the reason that I started doing this to
begin with,
which was,
you know,
really longterm wellness and,
and,
you know,
not having a heart attack like heart
disease runs in my family.
My grandfather who was a champion
swimmer died of a heart attack in his
early fifties.
And,
you know,
I have to constantly remind myself that
that was what motivated me to do this,
to begin with.
It wasn't performance reasons.
Um,
at the same time,
if I felt like I was missing something,
like if I started to feel like I wasn't
recovering or it wasn't improving or I
wasn't,
I wasn't able to get stronger or I
wasn't feeling good,
I would,
I would certainly entertain the
possibility of eating,
of eating meat if I thought my health
was suffering.
But I just haven't had that experience
yet,
so,
you know,
I just try to stick to,
I,
I don't want to speak for anyone else or
whatever.
So
how do you feel about that idea that
everybody's got a different sort of
nutritional requirement and that some
people really shouldn't eat red meat and
some people really should be
vegetarians.
It's like that.
It's uh,
you know,
based on your blood or where your
families origins are geographically and
that's the kind of genes that you're
carrying around.
I Dunno,
I don't really buy into any of that.
No,
no.
But has there been evidence that
different people that grow up in
different parts of the world have
different nutritional requirements?
Like for instance,
people that live in like Eskimos are
inuits,
they don't like to be called escalade
apparently.
Um,
inuits,
they,
they have no issues as far as like
scurvy or anything,
but they're not getting any vitamin C
than samples.
I have
like a,
they have a relatively high incidence of
heart disease.
Oh,
do they really do.
Yeah.
Um,
they,
um,
I thought the whole deal I was,
is it cancer that they,
the,
that you almost never see?
Yeah.
And annually population.
And they were attributing that to uh,
the uh,
nutrition that they got from fish oil.
Do you,
uh,
do substitute with any animal?
I'm like fish oil or anything like that.
No,
I mean,
you know,
I think getting your Omega threes is,
is really important.
Um,
you know,
fish oil is really popular with a lot of
people,
but you can essentially do the same
thing with flax seeds,
ground flax seeds.
I wouldn't,
I wouldn't use flax oil,
but like ground flax seeds or something.
I put in a vitamix all the time.
Why wouldn't choose the,
uh,
actual oil?
The oil has been linked to.
There's some evidence that suggests that
it's linked to incidents of prostate
cancer,
but for some reason the seeds aren't,
took the seeds,
the seeds have like the case,
you know,
like they have that casing on them or
whatever.
So you have to grind them up because
otherwise they'll just pass right
through you.
So I'm a kind of like a vitamix.
Yeah.
Or You can,
you can buy them ground or you can put
them in like a,
a coffee grinder or like a cuisinart or
something like that.
What about hemp oil?
It's supposed to be pretty neutral oil
and all that stuff has the same benefits
as fish oil and.
Well,
flax seeds are the closest from my
understanding.
Does it have the same benefits as far as
like a joint inflammation relief?
Because fish oil is incredible for,
for that.
I mean,
I think,
I think it's important when it comes to
joint relief and,
and looking at inflammation is looking
at the acidic or alkaline nature of the
foods that you're eating,
you know,
and,
uh,
animal products,
dairy,
meat tend to be very acid forming.
Like your body has a certain Ph,
right?
It's trying to,
it's trying to maintain that sort of Ph
right in the middle.
Um,
but you know,
the foods we eat and the toxins we
breathe in the air and stress of our
lives or whatever can all put,
you know,
try to push that one way or the other
and that our body has to kind of go into
hyperdrive to bring it back to its
normal state.
So the truth is,
is that most people that are eating a
standard American diet and you know,
living in North American way of life,
um,
are eating a predominantly acidic acid
forming diet and they're in a state of
what's called chronic acidosis.
And that's a,
that's a state in which you know,
you're constantly bombarding your body
with a very asset based diet and your
body has to kind of go into hyperdrive
to bring it,
to bring it back.
And that's an environment where you
become very rife for getting injured,
for getting sick.
And it's also,
you know,
an environment that is,
makes you more prone to those congenital
diseases.
So when you're eating a more plant based
diet,
those are,
those tend to be not every plant food or
whatever,
but it tends,
it tends to be in balance,
more alkaline forming and when you're,
when you're in a more alkaline state,
you're not getting sick,
you're recovering more quickly because
inflammation is,
is sort of the root cause for a zillion
diseases and it's like the enemy of the
athlete,
right?
You're always trying to like,
if you can reduce your inflammation,
your muscles are going to repair
themselves more quickly,
you're gonna be able to bounce back
quicker,
you'll be able to train harder.
It doesn't necessarily make you a better
athlete,
right?
You know,
in a short period of time.
But protracted over the course of the
season,
you're going to have a much more
efficient and effective training period.
And that's gonna result in performance
gains in the long run.
So you're essentially saying that all
the benefits of taking fish oil,
you could get those same benefits.
It would just changing your diet to a
vegetarian diet that you don't need fish
oil with respect
fish oil.
I mean,
the purpose of fish oil is to get those
omega threes,
those essential fatty acids,
right?
That are,
that are important.
I mean,
you know,
we,
there's a lot of talk about the fas and
the Omega six and the Omega three and we
get plenty of Omega six and all the
foods we eat or whatever,
but the problem comes when the ratio of
six to three is kind of off.
And most people don't get enough Omega
three in their diets and fish oil is
great for kind of rectifying that,
but it's just the,
you know,
my point is only that it's not the only
way of dealing with that.
What are the other vegetarian options
besides a hemp oil,
flax seed
oil and um,
uh,
walnuts.
I believe there's some nuts that are,
that are pretty high in how many do you
have to eat?
Hemp seeds?
Not that many.
Really.
You don't,
you don't need like a ton of this stuff
with fish oil.
Um,
I've been on like a really high fish oil
diet for a long time now.
I'd take like five,
5,000,
500 milligrams mill,
thousand milligram pill.
I take five of those in the morning and
five of those at night.
And when I don't do it,
I noticed a difference in how my joints
feel like from doing a lot of Jujitsu,
especially
I think interested in if you,
if you switched it up to um,
ground flax seeds if you felt a
difference or not.
Yeah,
I would be willing to try it.
But I always thought that it was like a,
almost like there was like lubricating.
It doesn't make sense really,
but that it was like deputy for doing
so.
Yeah,
it doesn't make sense.
We'd be like,
how much oil would you need to move up
the fucking.
And that's how I thought it in my head
because there was such a correlation
between taking these pills and joint
pain relief that I've found that a lot.
I read a lot of great things about fish
oil and studies on fish oil and there's
absolutely some nutritional benefit to
taking it.
I don't know why you wouldn't take it
unless it was because of the fact that
you wanted to,
um,
not have anything animal in your body,
like to just subscribe to.
Well,
I think
you,
you have to be careful with the toxins
that are in marine life too,
right?
Well,
it's all filtered by Ebola,
Carlson's fish oil,
that's all they,
they test that stuff and it's all
filtered out and there's nothing.
You don't have to worry about that.
And those are the very high end
companies.
They,
um,
they,
they test all their stuff,
but I just don't see why there would be,
um,
unless you were into it strictly from
the point of view of staying Vegan or
introducing no animal into your body at
all.
It doesn't seem like there's any thing
that you lose from taking fish oil.
There's um,
I mean,
it's interesting because anytime you say
this food is good,
then you can immediately go on the
Internet and find some reason why shot
or something.
You can fall into any category that.
And,
and uh,
there are,
there are some studies out there that
show that,
that the fish oil thing is a little
overhyped and you know,
I,
it's,
it's hard to quantify like who's right
and who's wrong and all that kind of
stuff.
Have you ever,
have you been to a,
a,
um,
there's a,
there's a guy named Dr Michael Greger.
He's got a site called nutrition
facts.org
and it's amazing.
It's good.
The guy has like a zillion,
he puts up videos like almost every day
and they're short.
They're like two to five minutes at Max
and you can look at,
you can enter in any food or any disease
or whatever and most likely as a short
video on it and it's all based on peer
reviewed scientific studies or whatever.
But I always go to that one.
I have a question about this food or
that.
It's a really good resource.
I went to a nutrition for the first time
when I was like 17 and I was losing
weight for martial arts competitions and
those fucking my body up and I was
trying to figure out how to monitor my
nutrition,
how to,
you know,
ilene myself out in the healthiest way
possible,
but drop the most weight before I had to
dehydrate myself.
But uh,
that was Nancy Clark who is pretty
famous for working with athletes.
She was in Boston at the time.
She's got a bunch of books on that stuff
and I think she's worked with,
uh,
other mma athletes to now this is way
after.
I mean,
I,
I must've done it,
did it with her and 85 or something like
that.
But that's when I first became,
it was from martial arts competition
before I had to worry about my diet.
I didn't,
I didn't watch what I ate at all.
I just ate what I felt like eating.
Even when I was competing,
I had no emphasis or focus on nutrition.
It wasn't until I got older that I do,
I just through trial and error and you
know,
just going on a whim and saying,
you don't want this.
I'm going to juice all day.
I'm just going to have beet juice and
carrot juice,
celery juice,
and I've done that a few times and you,
you,
you get.
This is a weird kind of energy that you
get from that intense plant nutrition
that you don't get from anything else.
You really don't.
It's not the same feeling that you get
when you have the satisfaction of a fat
rib eye and it's just perfectly cooked
and sliced into that medium.
Rare,
so good.
It's not that satisfaction,
but it is this weird sort of a vibrancy
that you get like you're injecting.
You're ingesting live live plants.
I mean essentially they've just died a
short period of time ago.
They're still vibrant with energy and
you don't get that from anything
processed and there's a lot of people
out there that are miserable,
that are depressed,
that are.
And I have friends that shit fucking
diets and their.
Their way of dealing with is take
antidepressants and it's like there's
no.
You've got to know exercise.
Terrible sleep shit.
Di You feel terrible.
Take a pill.
You feel better.
Really.
You've got to clean up all that other
stuff,
man.
And then see how you feel if you have
all these goddamn issues as far as your
diet,
as far as your sleep,
as far as,
you know,
stress levels get cleaned up.
That shit first before you go take a gun
damn pill.
I mean,
we're a nation of,
of crazy people who are addicted to all
these weird new,
not natural non native chemicals that
we're introducing into our body.
And that would become addicted to it.
I mean,
if we could just look,
if you could have a,
a,
an overlay of the United States and
who's on the influence of any sort of a
pharmaceutical drug right now.
It's like the Matrix.
I mean,
it really is.
And,
and,
uh,
you know,
not to spend too much of a new age
thing,
but you know,
you're,
you're right at the food carries a
vibrancy and an energy to it.
It's very specific.
And in my case,
I've been on this crazy amazing journey
that I would've never predicted and it
honestly started with changing my diet
and so I look at it with like a respect
and a reverence and I go,
this is,
this is what catalyzed this path.
And it opened me like,
it opened my heart to the possibility of
living differently and to doing
different things than I was doing.
And Look,
you know,
people are sicker than they've ever
been.
We're the,
we're such a prosperous nation and
people are just overmedicated.
They're fat,
they're unhealthy.
And for the most part they're people.
You know,
there's the,
what do you think the level of happiness
is now compared to what it was like 100
years ago?
Do you think we're happier?
Do you think we're more unhappy?
Well,
I think obviously it's an individual's.
I'm happy as fuck.
Yeah.
I mean,
the thing is you're doing what you're
meant to be doing.
You know what I mean?
You're on,
you're on a path that you know,
you've been blazing for a long time,
but you're,
you know,
you've made something happen that you're
passionate about.
But most people unfortunately don't live
that kind of life.
That's true.
But I think they could live their own
version of it
but,
but a lot of people don't.
And I know this because I was a
corporate lawyer.
I was miserable.
I was doing the 80 hour weeks and I had
done everything right my whole life
makes sense to do spine chill,
you know,
I studied hard,
I got into the good schools and I,
you know,
I played the game,
you know what I mean?
And I,
and I got to the place that was supposed
to be the brass ring,
you know,
and I was like,
what the fuck?
I was like not happy and I felt lost and
it's like a feeling of being in free
fall and you have a choice,
you can,
you know,
I was making a decent amount of money.
So you know,
a lot of people in that situation and
they'll just,
they'll just killed themselves with
stuff they can't afford.
Like,
well I'll,
I'll lease that car.
That's a little bit out of my reach.
And rewarding.
Yeah,
exactly.
Because when you're unhappy,
you know,
you need something to solve that,
that wound,
and then you do that long enough and
then you're stuck and you can't make a
change or it becomes too difficult.
And you know,
I think it was,
it was Henry David Thoreau that said,
the mass of men lead lives of quiet
desperation.
I think that's very,
very true.
One of my favorite quotes ever.
And it's,
it's sad,
man.
It's sad.
And you know,
I look at you,
you've built this thing here,
you're doing what you love.
You spend your day last Brian below.
But I mean,
you're,
you're like,
you know,
in your Juju.
You know what I mean?
Yeah.
And most people,
most people aren't.
I think that's okay.
So He's,
he's,
he knows Jews.
Yeah.
No,
most people aren't.
But they could be,
you know,
but I think one of those heart,
it's hard.
I mean,
you think it's hard to change your diet.
try overhauling your entire lifestyle.
Yeah.
Oh,
believe me.
Very,
very difficult and scary.
It's terrifying,
you know,
and we live in a fear based culture,
you know?
Um,
but I did it,
you know,
I went from being a martial arts
instructor to being a standup comedian
and got my car repossessed,
went broke,
lost all my critical.
I mean,
it was a,
a loser for like years that you were
willing to double down to do that.
I just didn't want to get brain damage.
I saw a future in kickboxing and I was
like,
you know what,
this is,
uh,
this,
this stuff is not good for your fucking
head.
And I was meeting guys that Jim,
the newer were punchy and uh,
I just was too one.
I did too many hard sparring sessions
where I never got knocked out in
sparring.
But I definitely got my bell rung
before.
Um,
and uh,
I got hit with hard shots before we
would,
we would trade,
you know,
I worked out at a particularly heavy
duty.
Jim and these,
the different gyms have different
philosophies as far as borrowing.
And our,
Jim's philosophy was he put on big
gloves and you fucking go at it.
There was,
there was,
it was basically kickboxing bouts with
big giant gloves on and headgear and
Shin Pads.
And stuff like that.
And uh,
I knew that it was not good for you.
So for me it was like I had this crazy
like I got to jump ship,
I got a job because this is a path of
deteriorating brain function.
Like I would have moments where I'd be
lying in bed and it wasn't even like
there was a,
like a goal,
like it wasn't,
there was no ufc back then.
So it was just kickboxing and in my
opinion,
like mixed martial arts is a,
first of all it's just way more options
and just because there's more options
you could protect yourself,
period.
There's no,
I mean you could say that mixed martial
arts fighters have damaged too,
and I'll tell you some do,
but there's some that don't have any.
There's some that rarely get hit and
that is possible as well.
And the,
the ability to mix up between the
striking and the grappling and the fact
that you have so many different options
if you have a creative and spontaneous
approach as well as being able to drill
things over and over again until they
become zen.
When you reach a certain level,
you can get away with way less damaged
than any boxer does.
Like you'll see a certain guys fight in
a five round UFC fight and take very
little damage like a George St Pierre
because he's so fucking good and his
plan is so good.
But with boxing and kickboxing,
you're standing in front of each other
and you're hitting each other period and
there's no downs and there's no.
There's no rear naked choke for the
finish and the first round does none of
that.
There's,
there's slamming bones into your head
trying to shut that Mellon off,
you know?
And ultimately for me,
I knew that I had to do something
differently as I was terrified and there
was no future in it,
you know,
but I.
But because of that I developed a real
compassion for understanding like how
difficult it is.
I was 21,
I had no children.
I had no.
I mean they'd repossessed my car so I
had no car anymore.
It was like,
it was really like I could live on the
cheap,
I could scratch by.
But if you're a person who is trying to
change careers and you have a family and
your mortgage and you have a car that
you lease and you've got to pay for your
kids' afterschool activities and that is
unbelievably hard,
very hard.
So then at the same time it's like,
you know,
life's short man,
and it's true,
most people are not,
are not doing what they,
what they want to be doing,
or maybe even what they're supposed to
be doing.
So what did you do?
How did you,
how did you just exit yourself out from
the machine?
Well,
I,
I had,
uh,
you know,
I left corporate law firm life and
started my own,
my own little thing and you know,
because I just couldn't,
I couldn't live that way anymore.
What little thing that you're talking
about?
Just a solo entertainment law practice.
Um,
and you know,
made a lot less money but was able to
control my time.
And that was just a little bit before,
you know,
I changed the Diet and started getting
back into fitness.
But because I had control over my day
because I didn't have a boss anymore,
I could set up my work schedule the way
that I want,
like Tim ferriss style.
Then it allowed me to be able to,
to,
um,
train at odd hours that wouldn't
necessarily flow with somebody,
you know,
nine to five job.
But I was able to structure my life so
that I could make that possible.
And again,
it was just feeling like,
you know,
when you feel like you're guided to move
in a certain direction in a certain
path,
you know,
when your car was repossessed and you
were starting to,
you know,
do stand up and move into that world.
I mean,
I'm sure you felt like this is what you
want it to be doing what you're supposed
to be doing.
Even if there was no kind of real world
material affirmation of that.
Initially
it was,
there was a lot of apprehension.
There was a lot of thinking that I was
fucking up,
but I was doing the wrong thing.
I mean,
there was a,
there was not much confidence.
It's certainly not like a,
I knew this was my path,
like I had an idea that this was
something that I could do,
but I was terrified because I sucked at
it too.
There was no evidence that I could ever
be really good at it.
When I quit teaching martial arts,
I mean I was teaching at Boston
University.
I had my own school and um,
I was,
uh,
it was making a living,
teaching taekwondo and then delivered
newspapers sometimes in the morning,
occasionally take newspaper routes.
Um,
I took to switch from that,
give up training and teaching entirely
altogether to,
to,
to do something that I wasn't very good
at.
It was fucking terrible.
That was a terrifying movie that I would
only make when I was 21.
And you know,
when you're 21
year old fucking cocky with.
But you know this like if I was going to
do that in this day and age,
is that really one of those old school
alarms right outside
you?
Dumb motherfucker.
But it'd be very hard for me to do
something like that today.
Well,
yeah,
it's different when you're 21,
but I mean is,
does anybody pay attention to car alarms
ever?
I don't know.
Open the door,
Brian and make it louder.
That's a good move.
Yeah.
Your instinct is never.
Oh my God.
Somebody stealing a car.
No fucking alarm is ruining our
conversation.
Is anybody anybody in,
in standup good in the beginning?
No,
because I heard that everybody says they
were,
you know,
they were awful when they can think that
they're good.
What are you doing,
man?
Shut up my microphone off.
There you go.
Um,
you,
you might think you're good.
I mean,
I've heard people say that they were
good right from the very beginning,
but they are either full of shit or they
were stealing jokes.
It just doesn't make sense that you were
good right from the beginning unless you
had some experience as something else
before.
One,
one group of people that were actually
pretty decent,
not bad for beginners was a alcoholics
anonymous people,
because this is driving people in
itunes.
Fucking crazy.
I guarantee you,
you want to take a quick five minute
break.
You might keep going right.
How long do these things keep going?
We'll just pause this folks.
We're going to pause this for a couple
minutes and let this shit stop.
Thank you.
This ladies and gentlemen,
we're very vulnerable folks technically.
Uh,
but we were in the middle of talking
about this shows off air.
There it goes.
Um,
we were in the middle of talking about
changing your life and changing,
you know,
changing your diet,
changing your path into something that
you love.
That's something that we stress on this
show,
like,
like as much as possible because it's
something that someone doesn't tell you
when you're growing up and the most
formative period of your life.
They don't say you.
You're different than me.
Everyone's different.
You have to find what you're drawn to.
Find what you love and then go chase.
That.
I love when I see is this mic on Brian?
It's working because I don't hear the
young people that like latch onto
something that they love doing when
they're,
when they're young,
you know,
whether it's playing the guitar or
whatever it is that they're just
passionate about.
And then they just become very self
directed about it and I'm like so
jealous.
I wish I had when I was a kid.
I wish I had that,
you know,
I'd never,
I spent my whole life kind of doing what
I was supposed to and didn't never
really stopped to think like,
well,
what do I,
what do I want or what makes me happy or
what am I passionate about?
It wasn't really,
just wasn't really part of my equation,
you know?
And that just seems so wrong.
So it's like,
yeah,
it's terrible.
And,
and,
and it,
it,
it almost like it doesn't even matter
what it is,
you know,
everybody has something inside them that
they probably,
you know,
love doing or could be passionate about
or could be good at or whatever.
And
for everyone,
do you think there's some people
stickers?
Not Listen,
I think that not look,
not everyone can be an nba basketball
player or whatever.
So not everyone is innately gifted,
but I think everybody in signed the
inside of themselves has something that
makes them happy.
And I think that if you pursue what
makes you happy without getting so
caught up in,
how am I going to make money doing this
or there's no career in it,
whatever,
and living a little bit more faith based
with what you're doing and focusing more
on the passion that you know,
we'd probably be,
we'd probably be better off.
I think people would be happier if that
was a priority.
There will also be cultural people
already trying to borrow money.
There'll be a lot more people.
Well Hollywood's full of these kinds of
people.
Of course there'll be a lot more people
that need a loan to try to get through
this next thing that they're trying to
fucking get launch.
Kickstarter would have got it done in a
long time ago.
Yeah.
King started changed the whole game of
begging.
Made it kind of cool.
So you've figured out a way to put a
name to it that makes it seem,
oh,
it's Kevin just kickstart and my
business.
Did you see,
I just saw,
I tweeted this yesterday,
right?
That this,
this company came up with this New Light
Bulb that you can control your,
your iphone app,
you can,
you put all these light bulbs in your
house and you can do all this crazy
stuff with them.
Like change all their colors.
Yeah.
Like that,
like changed the cars,
have them turn on,
have them like,
you know,
on timers that go off and,
and it was pretty cool.
But they raised a ton of money on
kickstarter.
No Shit.
Yeah,
I'm sure.
Yeah.
It's a brilliant idea.
And you,
you know,
you,
there's all sorts of different offers
that companies give to people that you
can actually become a part of.
Like cocaine cowboys.
I thin he do something like that where
he.
No,
no,
that wasn't,
that was the union.
The guys who did the union,
his next film that he's doing,
he,
he got people to buy it in advance on
kickstarter instead of just like asking
for money.
He said,
listen,
I'm giving you your,
you'll get the first copies of this
film.
A successful product
ones are all,
they're almost preorders.
So there was a lot of money because
you're going to actually get the
product.
Yeah,
I mean it sounds like it's such a.
it's like the people that enjoyed the
first film can actually fund and finance
the second one.
I mean,
it's just,
it's really cool,
you know,
if you look at it that way,
it's really cool.
I mean,
we live in,
we live in the most strange times.
This is a really.
Things like that,
you know,
are just like,
you can do that.
Yeah,
you could do that and you can make a lot
of money.
Let's look at these fucking guys that
made millions of dollars of this.
Where did that go?
By the way?
That fucking was the quickest out fad
that coney fad man,
that's almost like an alien blip.
They just tested us for retardation,
like a Ph test from the,
from the heavens in the same way that is
accelerating.
Our attention spans are shrinking.
You know?
It's amazing.
The rapidity with which stuff comes and
goes now,
like it's immediate like it be.
It can be the biggest thing ever.
And then it's immediately.
Could you imagine though Joseph,
his email box?
It's like nothing thin,
thin,
millions of emails stop.
It was just nothing,
nothing.
He's not getting the emails today.
Joseph Kony doesn't even get Nigerian
scammer emails today.
That was just viral marketing for Peter
Pan on Blu Ray.
Yeah,
totally.
And yet at the same time you do this
podcast and you hold people's attention
for three hours a day.
Man,
that's ridiculous.
These people need to get outside,
stop listening to this fucking show,
go mow your lawn sign.
But they're probably willing to ask a
lot of people do it while they're
working,
which is cool as fuck because then they
get to be a part of a conversation
instead of just be sitting there,
you know,
screwing widgets together.
I got on my long training rides.
I just stack it with podcasts because I
cannot,
I can't if I'm going out to ride my bike
for a long day,
eight hour training ride or something
like that.
I can't listen to music the whole time,
you know?
I'd go insane.
So I,
I,
I'll listen to your podcast,
a couple other podcasts and I just
stopped and I just lose myself in the
conversation.
So for me it's like the longer the
better man.
I love it.
Yeah,
we will.
When we first started out,
everybody was telling him we were crazy
for doing an hour.
Our Ari Shapiro was constantly go,
go,
go to a job.
More than older people are not going to
listen.
I go,
well,
how about this?
This don't listen to the rest.
They just shut it off at any point in
time.
Like what fucking difference.
Does that make sense?
This is ridiculous.
It's two hours,
three hours.
You don't have to listen.
Like,
do I get bummed out that a radio shows
in four hours long?
I only was in my car for an hour.
No,
you listen to whatever the fuck you want
to listen to it.
I think the key is just giving people
content.
Just keep keeping it coming.
That's the most important thing is the
momentum,
keeping it coming and then you become a
part of people's sort of daily routine.
And when you become a part of people's
daily routine,
then you have an obligation and a
responsibility to keep it coming,
you know,
because like now you're bombing a bunch
of people out.
It's not as simple as you put something
out and they enjoy it.
It's,
you don't put it out and you bummed them
out.
Like,
what the fuck?
Fucking angry with you.
Fucking jewelry expectation.
Yeah.
But it's,
you're,
uh,
you're making junkies and you,
you have to feed those junkies.
I mean,
it seems like you're keeping the quality
really high.
That David Seaman interview was amazing.
I'd never,
I'd never even heard of that guy.
I was like,
why is he having like a guy's running
for Congress on his show?
I just thought,
and I listened to it.
I was like,
that is amazing.
I immediately started following him.
He's coming back,
he's doing it to gas and dating guy.
And it's a real interesting.
I was thinking about it the other day
because he's the first guy from like
that generation to be in this sort of,
you know,
a political candidate.
Yeah.
And uh,
and the generation gap is very palpable
president,
a very different place and his
priorities
and perspectives and all of that or so
just in the way he speaks or so
different from what we're used to,
you know what I mean?
But he's smart.
He's a smart kid.
He's like 26 years old.
It's beyond my shit he is.
But it's beyond that too because,
you know,
he is interested in things and is
talking about things that no one in,
you know,
the traditional political stratosphere
want to get anywhere near,
right wild.
It could either he'll wind up being
killed or he'll be the new king.
Right?
Either way,
we got your backs on,
uh,
you know,
I,
I think it's,
uh,
it's,
it's very important that the only way
this future is going to be any brighter
is if it's very important that we
enlightened young people coming up to
alternative paths of thinking.
But you telling your story that you had
gone down the exact correct path,
you know,
in,
in some sort of a predetermined pattern
to success,
which would equal happiness supposedly
for you.
And then reaching that point of success,
you,
you're not speculating ema,
you were one of the rare people that
actually made it to the end of the game
and went,
this is horseshit.
Okay,
let's get outta here and you can't get
trapped here.
Let's get the fuck out of here and try
something different.
It has to be done.
That message when that message is in
some kid's ear bud,
when he's on the train headed to his job
or or headed to school or whatever.
That that message can resonate and
change thousands of people's lives.
I have had more fucking people come up
to me in the past two years and say,
your podcast changed my life then than
any than any one thing that people have
said to me other than fear is not a
factor.
They probably said that anything else,
but that,
that key,
that fucking theme keeps happening.
And a lot of it is nutrition and a lot
of it is exercise,
but a lot of it also is just this
understanding that you're not alone in
thinking like that.
That the standard path seems like shit.
You're not alone in that,
it's your,
there's a lot of other people like us
out there and we could all get pigeon
holed into some ridiculous patterns that
were created without individual
personalities and unique traits and
artistic intentions and qualities in
mind of that stuff in mind.
They were just,
this is a plumber,
this is a vacuum salesman.
This is go down that path.
So I'm,
you'll be an electrician and you know,
we're,
we're disconnected from our own
heartbeat.
You know what I mean?
It's like you could say,
well,
you know,
most people are like,
well,
I don't even know what I like.
You know,
it's like we're not,
we're disassociated from like a higher
version of ourself.
More authentic version that wants to
come out is locked down so deep that
it's almost like the key is,
you know,
unfindable well,
we've become a.
We become a victim of our own culture,
our own creation,
the culture of our own creation as a
culture of predetermined patterns and
obligations and things that you just
must do that a lot of them suck and we
become a prisoner to that and this idea
that if you do those things somehow or
another,
you will be happier.
It's ludicrous.
It's ridiculous.
Yeah.
But then there's also,
you have to pay your fucking rent and
you know you want to drive.
Cars is expensive.
Gas is expensive.
Well,
what are you gonna do you gotta you
gotta get a job,
son.
It's finding the,
the ability to pay yourself,
feed yourself and on top of that still
pursue a dream.
That's the hardest thing.
You going to do it before you develop
any fucking baggage.
Live lean.
Yeah.
When you're young.
That I could've done one thing when I
was young.
It was just the live as lean as possible
and keep all those doors and options
open so you don't get stuck in someplace
you don't want to be and and,
and make it more difficult for yourself
to get out.
Yeah,
I got out,
but I could have easily just not gotten
out.
I know a lot of people that didn't know
a lot of people that are postman
somewhere that really wanted to be a
rockstar.
You know,
there's a lot,
a lot of weirdness in this world,
and then the one of the most depressing
things to be around is someone who never
went for it.
The people that you know that never went
for,
that had an idea in their head,
whatever it is,
being an author,
they just never changed.
I want to be a longshoreman and I want
to be a fucking professional fisherman.
I wanna.
I want to fucking do what those crab
guys doing.
That crazy show guys go fishing for crap
just to fucking know I'm alive.
If you have that thought in your head
and you don't do it,
you're gonna.
You're living like a bitch,
man.
You don't want to.
You don't want to have those regrets,
man.
It's the saddest thing in the world,
isn't it?
Yeah.
The,
the,
the feeling that you get when you're
around someone who just stayed on the
couch,
just never pursued anything artistic.
Anything physical,
anything,
anything.
For me it always feels like one of the
big things of,
of happiness.
It's like seeing improvement.
Either seeing improvement in stuff that
I'm working on,
like comedy stuff or seeing improvement
and um,
my uh,
my Jujitsu or seeing improvement in
playing pool A,
anything to me it's like if I don't see
improvement and things then I get like,
I get really bummed out.
Like I feel like I'm not doing anything.
I feel lazy.
I feel like I'm just getting by,
you know,
if I'm,
if I go four or five days where I'm not,
like at least actively working on
improving some aspect of my life,
I feel it's totally lazy.
Right to it found out that Matt Danzig
with them.
Is that what is,
why?
Why is it,
why would that make it haunted?
Because his,
his podcasts are haunted.
Oh,
his podcast.
That's right.
He said to podcasts that fucked up Ari
[inaudible] podcast.
He did this long podcast with Ari fear
and uh,
it got deleted and they couldn't return.
We couldn't retrieve it.
And then mine,
which just crashed recently.
So he made me podcast haunted.
Is he going to come?
He's coming back.
Come coming tomorrow.
Yeah,
tomorrow is going to be a crazy day,
ladies and gentlemen.
We have not just powerful Mac.
Dan's like,
we have billy Corbin who's the director
and producer of cocaine cowboys.
He's coming in with Mad Flavor,
Aka Joey Diaz.
So Diaz and the director of cocaine
cowboys and Joey's on the phone with me
yesterday who's dropping knowledge.
He's telling me he was warming up for
this.
He goes,
let me tell you something,
dog.
I'm going to tell people shit I never
told before.
The tell people shit I never told
before.
Joe Rogan,
I'm going to go back to my uncle.
We can call them in Miami.
Seventy years old,
he'll tell you what the fuck happened.
And he started going off and screaming
at me on the phone after he screamed at
me for leaving a message.
I fucked up and left a voicemail message
on his machine.
If you leave a message as machine,
he'll will go crazy and call you up and
motherfuck you.
Why?
He doesn't want to listen to messages.
Yeah,
but he gets angry at you.
So if you call his voicemail,
it goes,
what the fuck did I tell you know,
messages do not leave a message on this
fucking phone.
So if you leave a message,
he goes bananas.
Even if you have like tell them to turn
that,
you can turn that off.
Can you know these Joey fucking ape?
He doesn't know what cash.
Unless every job.
That phone might as well be solid wood.
He doesn't know what the fuck the
buttons to shuts off when it runs out of
batteries in his hands to somebody.
He's getting better at that though.
He sent me text messages before and I
stuck it in his face.
I go,
what the fuck is this?
You sent me a text message for the
longest time.
Joe.
He just had a pager when everyone had
cell phones.
He still had a pager.
Yeah.
He didn't have a cell phone until like
the two thousands.
I'm not bullshitting neither man.
Joey Diaz had a.
Did he have a pager when you met him?
He might've had a pager when you met
him.
Yeah.
He kept a pager deep,
deep into his history on a lot of people
had given up the ghost in the pager.
It's weird how these things just haven't
been around that long and yet you can't
even imagine not having them anymore.
Do you remember the transitionary period
where a lot of a lot of folks in the
urban community had those little pagers
that would send messages?
You could send like a little message to
somebody meet me at the club.
They would that the black folks were way
ahead of the curve on that.
They were way ahead of the curve.
I never thought that would have caught
on like,
what are you guys doing?
You're texting a white tank.
I didn't even say texting wasn't even
called texting.
I was like,
you're writing each other letters like,
why do you,
why are you doing that?
And they were like,
well,
it gets loud in the club.
I was like,
Oh,
it gets loud in the club.
That makes sense.
That's what started it all for real.
That's it was too loud in the club.
People fast for her to the.
I found not only that,
but a lot of times,
uh,
there's another thing that is a
phenomena in the urban community that
you'd like to talk on speakerphone.
No,
I don't know what's up with that.
I've talked about this on his podcast
and people have accused me of being
racist,
touching that right after they accused
me of being racist.
I went to Roscoe's chicken and waffles
and there's a dude standing right in
front of the place talking on his phone
like this.
Oh Hell No.
They'll do.
Was talking loud.
You could hear the other dude like
silver loud and he's maybe he liked,
heard the sheryl crow story and is
worried about brain tumors,
but I don't think so.
I think there's something going on.
Like they even had a commercial.
Remember that commercial for boost
mobile.
They would have their cell phones like
where you at?
They would talk into it.
They're not doing this.
You're not treating it like a white
person phone.
Now they're holding it.
You at that was the,
that was the commercial they were doing
urban style.
It's a weird thing.
So I guess that didn't work.
You know,
cell phones and clubs.
It's when you're on gone speakerphone
all the time.
It's fucking shit.
It's fucking chaos.
Right.
So imagine,
remember I used to have jokes in my act
about text messages were stupid before,
like in 2005,
my showtime special.
I totally marked text messaging like it
takes you four presses to get an ass.
I was like,
there was before anybody had keyboards.
Yeah.
People would like,
they were starting out with that crazy
shit.
We would have to press four times to get
in that ladder.
Right?
Yeah.
That was ridiculous.
You remember that were dinosaurs.
I remember when the texting plans were
like 25 texts per month.
50 texts per month.
Yeah.
If you've got a girlfriend,
you go through the day.
No girls love texting.
People are dying and crashing their cars
because they just can't keep their
fingers off it.
Oh yeah.
It's real issue.
It's a real issue.
They say it's one of the worst
distractions ever that you literally
cannot focus on your phone.
Like it's like zooming in on something
like that and intently is like,
it's so.
It's so non peripheral.
You don't see anything peripheral.
You've completely concentrated on that
thing.
Right.
Some lady almost ran into me at the mall
the other day.
She was on her phone and she was doing
this and she looked up and I was like,
right in the crosswalk.
People are fucking nuts man.
They're nuts and we've created this
weird culture again that were prisoner
to.
And one of the prisons is technology.
I mean we,
we benefit from it,
no question about it,
but we are also locked into this really
weird symbiotic relationship with it.
Like I am.
I do not leave my house without my phone
man.
If I,
I,
if I don't have my phone on me,
I feel weird.
That is weird.
Family.
Where's my fucking phone?
And I'll panic.
Even though it's like all you have to do
is you buy a new phone and you stick it
in your computer,
all your contacts.
It takes you.
I mean if you lost your phone,
it's not the most,
but the other people,
I'm alone,
I'm out there on my own with no,
no tether.
It's like they were afraid to be in a
fucking town without a cell phone.
I mean,
I feel bizarre if I leave,
if I,
if I'm in a town like say in a.
it's like a place where you could walk
around and I leave my phone in my hotel
room and then I'll go downstairs and
I'll just walk to a restaurant,
sit down.
I feel fucking strange.
Like I feel like I can't talk to anybody
right now.
It's worth it.
And it gets even crazier with all the
social media.
Like you have this compulsion to check
twitter and see what certain people are
saying that you don't even.
These are people you don't even know.
Well,
some people have it hooked up to their
phone where they get a text message
every time someone tweets any sort of a
mention of their name,
you know?
That's,
that's insane.
Don Benson has that.
So does dot Merera.
I tweeted a instagram the other day,
a picture of Don Merera,
the sexy pool boobs was shooting pool
and uh,
it showed up on his phone.
I'm like,
silly bitch.
Turn that shit off.
I'll have people just read.
I think I already have do that now your
phone is going to blow up tomorrow.
This is insane.
It just scrolls like crazy.
Yeah,
you can't read all that stuff.
I read as much as I can,
but the problem is some people think I
read it all and they're like,
did you respond to my [inaudible]?
Get Mad at you responding to tweet and
like,
doors tomorrow.
What tweet do you want me to really go
into your thing?
And there's a lot of people here.
Do just,
you had the chance to say it again right
there.
And he didn't.
You just said bullet foods do not
respond.
Foods dealt with.
Oh,
the negative approach.
I get the guilt move.
Always,
always good.
I was here in Howard stern talking about
twitter,
about how many people are nasty to him
on twitter and how evil they are.
Um,
I don't get that.
I really don't get this pretty
overwhelmingly positive compared to
other platforms that I've found.
I get overwhelmingly positive.
I mean there's always a few cons,
but it's so easy to block them,
my wife and bring them on it.
And it's rare.
It's really rare and I think a lot of
people on twitter,
like you look at their names,
it's like that's their real name.
It's,
it's more than a St message boards,
message boards.
I've always felt like we have a message
board on Joe Rogan Dot Net and I've
always felt like prior to the problem is
the anonymity that it provides.
In a way.
It's good because people can talk about
things,
especially like people that have
sensitive jobs and people that are at
work,
they can get away with talking about
things and there's no way to google them
and data reference their name,
but in a way it's bad because people say
shit without any reason.
They don't worry about the,
uh,
the social repercussions of looking at a
person's eye and calling them a country
Douche bag,
you know?
And then they're like,
what the fuck man,
you didn't like that.
That negativity is gone.
So it's just these verbal barb's.
I think with twitter,
like a lot of times people have their
photo that's there.
It's not everybody but a good
percentage.
Like I'm looking at my,
my twitter feed.
Most of these are people's names.
Real people.
Yeah.
There's a few that aren't because a few
like weird names or you know,
it's like maybe one of them's Divo
bitch,
you're not Divo,
you know,
and it's depo is me.
Is his twitter name to Divo son.
I mean you might like diva but you're
not divo and who are you really?
It's probably the name is Mike Callahan
or whatever the fuck his name is.
When I think the more we have that,
the more we have like a sort of a
transparency about who I think people
are less likely to just lash out and
have it become super.
Yeah,
that's true.
I mean I think like a couple of weeks
ago when you had,
you retreated like a video I made of a
Kale shake or something like that.
We had a back and forth over Kale,
vitamix or something like that,
so.
So you retweeted this stupid little
video that I made of just me making a a
drink after a run and I got slammed with
desk squad,
army full of fact.
Just like if I saw that guy on the
street I would,
I would stab him in the face and like,
what is it?
Like the most benign thing my face for
me,
it's not.
Yeah,
exactly.
really.
I mean there were some that were fine
too,
but I was like suddenly out of the blue,
like all these comments popped up,
so it's clearly as a result of you
having this huge following or whatever.
Have you though for your dietary choice
are very threatened by the Kale Joe?
Yeah.
That's what they don't know what to do
with me because I enjoy the Kale.
I love the Kale.
I'm,
I'm a big fan of,
of pure vegetable,
just meals.
It's just food is just food,
but the people need to be on a fucking
team.
Okay.
It's now during the desk about army and
if,
if they feel like they're being attacked
by vegetarian,
they'll fucking throw out all their
vegetables.
I don't know why,
you know,
we all just get along to quote Rodney
King for drown on PCP and a swimming
pool.
It's a,
it seems to me that,
uh,
the real problem is annoying people.
It's not vegetarian meat eaters.
It's not.
The real problem is annoying people or
people that are ignoring that.
That's the issue.
It's not your different ideology or
different desire.
I know people that legitimately really
love classical music and they can't wait
to get home to put on headphones and sit
there in front of some shit.
That to me,
which is a drive me out of my head.
I can listen to classical music for a
couple minutes and then I go,
you know what I can be listening to
right now led Zepplin.
Why am I listening to this stupid shit
when I can hear a whole lot of love?
You know,
to me,
I don't like classical music,
but it doesn't mean that it's not
awesome to you.
You know?
It's the same thing with dietary
choices.
Same thing that the way you dress.
I've had it,
man.
He just enjoy your life.
We've lost a little bit of a tolerance,
dense intolerance,
you know,
it's one of the dumbest things to lose
its,
you know that diversity is a good thing.
Huge.
So why?
You know,
why are you taking a dump on somebody
else's preference that has nothing to do
with you?
Yeah,
and by the way,
tolerance and acceptance of people
benefits your life very much directly.
It benefits the way you feel.
The more tolerant and accepting you are
a people and the more you don't know,
you're just cool with people.
The more positive interactions you'll
have,
the more positive interactions you'll
the better your your,
your feeling in life will be.
And that's like a real direct thing for
sure.
And that the,
the negative shit that a lot of people
project at people for no reason.
What it really is,
is your own shortcomings and magnified
through your personality traits.
It has nothing to do with the person
that's being projected.
A very rarely does.
Very rarely does he just choose them to
for your eye or the target of your
bullshit,
but the reality is you wouldn't have
that bullshit.
Like,
I try to explain this to a guy once who
was a heckler.
I know that.
I was like,
you're,
you have to be a loser.
There's no way it can be a winner.
You know what I'm saying?
Like,
do you really think that Michael Jordan
would go to a comedy club and haggle?
Do you think anybody who'd be really
good at anything would interrupt a
performance and just try to interject
now you have no appreciation for things
that are good.
Like,
this is a,
this is,
uh,
a dire moment for you where you need to
realize this.
Anybody who would try to fuck up
someone's time,
if you're trying to fuck up their
enjoyment,
you're trying to,
you've got something wrong with you,
man.
You got something wrong with you 100
percent.
There's no way around it.
You have to be fucked up.
And if you weren't that way,
you would be happier.
Believe it or not,
like that energy that you put out is
palpable.
The energy that you put out being an
asshole is real and it does come.
It does flavor.
Your light comes back.
Yeah.
And for you,
you feel that's a dietary as well,
right?
So what do you mean?
You mean?
I mean as far as like putting out energy
mean you're taking in vegetables,
you're almost like a pure,
you know,
that that existence of,
of,
of only eating vegetables and not,
not being connected to animal farming or
any of that horrible shit that you see
and we're still all connected to it,
you know,
but just by virtue of living here and
all the other things that we have to do,
do you drive a prius posts?
I know if you drive a van,
like a fucking muscle cars,
we're very proud of you.
I wish I could fucking.
What are we?
What have we been talking about these
past two hours?
I really wish you really wish.
I know it needed to get a kickstart,
tapped out and to get a CTO.
A muscle car.
Yeah.
No,
there's a certain,
um,
I guess it's,
you know,
it sounds weird to say it,
but there's definitely like a feeling of
like greater harmony.
The environment makes sense.
It sounds really stupid.
It doesn't,
you know,
I'm,
I'm going hunting for the first time in
October with Steve Rinella.
He's a guy who had a TV show on the
travel channel called the wow within and
now he's got a new one called the
mediator and his show is essentially his
original show was all about,
um,
you know,
like sort of like living off the land
and he would do a lot of things that
were like really similar to what like,
um,
uh,
people had to do in the 18 hundreds,
like you would kill a water buffalo with
a musket and shit like that.
And his new show.
It's all about,
uh,
what you call like fair chase hunting.
And one of the things that I've been,
I'm really paying attention to a lot
lately is the idea of a hunter gatherer
lifestyle being I'm actually,
uh,
like a physically benefiting experience
for people and that there are certain
amounts of,
there's a certain system or a reward
system that's a in our bodies that is a
satisfied with growing your own food.
There's a certain reward system that's
satisfied with the hunting and fishing
and that our bodies are essentially the
same as the bodies of people that lived,
you know,
20,000
years ago.
There's very little genetic change and
that we still have these reward systems,
these primal feelings
of satisfaction that are built into our
very being as a human being in order to,
to,
to motivate us to do the correct things
to survive and to carry on.
And I'm at,
me personally as a,
as a person who is a mediator.
I've never killed an animal ever,
you know,
except accidentally like car accidents
and shit.
You know,
I've never like went hunting.
I've never actually,
I shot a squirrel with a bb when I was
little.
I think I might've killed that little
guy.
Sorry,
sorry.
Squirrel.
But what I'm saying is I've never hunted
anything and killed what I,
you know what I,
and I don't know how I'm going to feel,
you know,
I might,
I might shoot a deer and be like,
okay,
fuck this.
I need to get some beats because I'm
done with this.
Or I might go,
well,
you know what,
if I didn't shoot that thing,
it would probably get hit by a car or it
would get killed by a coyote or you
know,
it's going to die.
It's not going to live forever and
become magical.
What's the term you used?
Fair,
fair chase,
fair chase.
What does that mean?
That means you don't set a bait.
You don't put out like bait and leave
food and very certain certain spot over
and over again so that you know,
the animals will be there.
In Texas,
they actually have feeders where they
have these giant drums that dispense
food on a timer.
So in the morning,
the deer just start walking in because
they know they're going to get fed
because most of the time you're not
hunting there because they have giant,
what they call high fence ranches and
these high fence ranches,
it's essentially like they've converted.
They've done like a mixture of farming
and hunting because it's like,
it's really like farming.
I mean you're just harvesting,
meet the animal.
You're in a blind.
The animal walks out the spot.
He goes to every day,
goes to get his food above bloomy.
His heart blows out of his chest and
he's done.
He lives there with his legs kick in.
You turned them into meat and you cook
them up.
And that's,
that's a way more humane solution for
sure,
than a factory farm.
No doubt about it.
And I'm not criticizing it,
but that's not what Steven Rinella does
with Steven Nella does he,
he believes that the real satisfaction
comes from like stocking the game,
finding the right place to be when
you're,
you know,
upwind or downwind and getting away from
the area where the animal can detect you
and you know,
and stalking and hunting an animal the
way people did thousands and thousands
years ago.
Did you read,
did you read that book?
Born to run?
No.
So what is it?
It's called born to run by Christopher
mcdougall.
It's an amazing book.
He's a contributing writer to I think
men's journal or outside magazine or
something like that was a hugely
successful book that,
that uh,
let me shut this door.
There's people in our.
Oh,
sorry.
Anyway,
this guy went down to,
uh,
the Copper Canyon in Mexico,
which is this really remote area and I
think it's in the northern part of
Mexico,
but below that,
the Arizona board or somewhere
and it's like a land lost in time,
like it's impossible to get in and out
of there.
And there are these tribes in there
called the Tarahumara and uh,
they're like this,
uh,
this uh,
population of endurance runners that
essentially run barefoot with these
little,
they have little sandals or whatever,
and,
and they'll run incredible distances
and in the course of the book he gets
to,
he gets to sort of commune with these
people and it goes into kind of like
ultra running and the barefoot running
movement and the history of how they're
running.
You know,
how Nike sort of created this business
around running shoes.
And it's fascinating.
But I'm,
one of the things he talks about is this
theory that man evolved as a persistent
hunter as and that and that we were,
we evolved to be endurance runners
because we would go to chase down these
animals that were better,
faster than us that have much more fast
twitch muscle.
We could,
you can't run as fast as them,
but eventually they just,
they get exhausted.
They can't run days at a time.
And these humans would just patiently
like sort of track them and just follow
them and follow them and follow them.
And then just wait until the animal,
like keeled over out of dehydration,
exhaustion and that's how they would
conquer the animal and bring it back to,
to eat people still do it today.
Right.
And so,
so the idea that we were sort of bred to
be endurance athletes or runners out as
a result of this,
you know,
thousands of however many thousands of
years of doing this.
That's fascinating.
So,
uh,
did they,
um,
did they use weapons when they first did
it or did they just strangle them and
hit them with a rock once they.
Yeah,
I think it was sort of like,
it was a really.
They,
these animals,
they'd be so exhausted that there wasn't
much need to do anything severe.
Like they'd kill over.
They get him with a rock or if we really
knew for sure.
It's like really funny when you have
like things like that.
Like how did we develop disability to do
this?
When did they figure out about
persistence,
hunting and running.
It will be really amazing if we could
know for sure.
It's so funny about how much of like the
past of human beings is like this weird
ideas where you're trying to like piece
it together and like formulate a vision
of how things went down.
It's really hard to just extrapolate
that across,
you know,
in,
and apply it to a certain nutritional
way of living.
Like,
you know,
with Paleo,
it's sort of all right,
well Paleolithic,
but you know,
how many,
how many thousands of years ago are we
talking about are millions of years ago
for a million,
40 million,
40,000,
right?
What is it,
where your body,
what part of the world and you know,
certain people's evolved to had an
approach to food because of what was
available to them in a different way
than somewhere else.
And,
and piecing that puzzle together is.
I mean it's tricky and they've just
started finding some really interesting
things that show that you might be
dealing with far,
far older societies than we think in the
first place I could.
They were always pushing the dates back
of like when people figured certain
things out,
like there's some cave art that they've
discovered
now that they're,
they're looking at like 40,000
plus years ago and you're like,
okay,
this is,
this is just throws things way back,
you know,
there's,
it's a,
it's really a fascinating thing trying
to piece together what human beings,
how we become what we are right now and
what led us to this point,
this,
this apex of 2012.
The whole process of hunter and
gathering of.
I mean that's where people,
a lot of people say the thing went wrong
and we developed agriculture.
That's one of the thing went wrong.
Then we figured out how to have a
surplus because then we had to defend
that surplus and then we had this big
fucking forte,
but that was also sort of the birth of
civilization and the and the intellect
to where it went wrong.
What went wrong?
Man,
we fucked it up,
fucked it up.
I thinking we could have been having a
great time back in the spending a week
chasing down one because yeah,
the video where the guy does it,
he does it in Africa.
The video that I saw and he's fucking
persistent.
Haunting,
so he just lit.
How long did it take him forever.
It was a long day.
He just kept chasing this fucking thing
and at the end he was so tired and the
they said that the guy doesn't even eat
it.
The Guy who kills the animal didn't even
eat it out of respect for the process or
you know,
the connection that he has to the
animal,
which we.
That's the weirdest thing.
And I think one of the weirdest things
about human beings is our lack of
connection to what food is.
You know,
people that are,
they get upset if you want to go hunting
yet they're wearing leather.
People that eat meat but would never
kill it themselves.
It's like we've really like figured out
a way to completely disconnect people
from the process,
which I just can't.
I can't see that being natural while
still living with this ignorance denial.
And disassociation are very powerful and
they're,
they're powerful defense mechanisms for
just getting through the day.
Yeah.
How do you fix that?
How do you,
how do you,
uh,
is there a way to,
to inspire,
inspire in the classroom some,
a different way of looking at things so
that people don't grow up to be the same
fucked up pattern monkeys over and over
and over again?
Well,
it's weird because in some ways I feel
like it's changing and it's getting
better and in an otherwise I feel like
it's moving backwards.
I mean,
when you have the Internet and you have
all this unbelievable amount of
information available to you where you
can find out anything in an instant and
you can get to the bottom of what's
happening in subject x,
uh,
that's like a good thing,
right?
Like,
it pulls the covers on a lot of people
and a lot of organizations and what have
you.
And yet at the same time you have
traditional media that's becoming even
more and more entrenched.
You know,
it's sort of like remember when we were
kids it was like the local news and that
was how you got your news,
you're going to believe what they tell
you and and now it's with the Internet,
it's,
you watch the news and you're like,
well I don't know if that's the whole
story and saying this and it's easy to
go online and,
and you know,
extrapolate upon that
and find out more and figure out why
they're not telling you this part of the
story or that.
Whereas he didn't have that before.
Yet at the same time I feel like we're
more and more entrenched in this fear
based culture in which there's a clamp
down and so where does that lead us?
Like is it ultimately,
does that like implode on itself or like
where,
what,
how does it all play out?
How does that all play out?
That's the question,
right?
I mean it is playing out and I think,
believe it or not,
without sounding grandiose,
conversations like this are a part of
the decision making process.
It's a part of how society looks at it,
about,
about how we approach it,
because there's a lot of people that are
like you that realizes this is,
that this is not natural,
this is,
is this whole thing is bizarre and it
can go wrong.
It can all go wrong.
The whole fear based culture that you
brought up,
the idea of the,
the,
the lack of civil liberties,
uh,
the lack of privacy that we really have
in this country now,
the laws that are being passed over and
over again that allow people to look
into your stuff because you might be a
terrorist.
I mean,
how did we not learn from the mccarthy
era?
How did we not learn that the way is not
to crack district.
We're distracted by our iphones and the
Kardashians and you know what I mean,
like people are,
there is a malays know and,
and technology,
you know,
plays a huge part in that,
in distracting us.
Like again,
it's like the Matrix,
you know,
it's crazy.
Well,
I said it's weird because you used to
be,
if you were to talk about this kind of
stuff or propose any of these ideas,
you were just a crazy conspiracy
theorist,
but now it's,
there's too many crazy things going on
too to not realize that there's a lot of
truth to all this stuff.
I mean everything from like the the
label on the front of a food product
that you buy that's telling you this and
that when you turn around and look at
the nutrition facts panel and you
realize it's nonsense.
Or how about genetically modified foods
now?
That's insane.
Have you had looked at.
I mean
it,
you know,
so I mean the people that are making
them.
Have you looked down the road 20 years
and found out what people are gonna?
What's gonna happen when peanut elite
these,
what's going to alter the environment
like your past.
You're developing a fucking thing that
has a natural pessimist
and humans are not.
We're not wired to be forward thinking
or to consider the long play.
You know,
we're a bunch of scary creeps button
pushing these monkeys banks.
Until recently somebody said,
I can't remember where I heard this,
but if all the insects died that uh,
if all,
if all the insects died,
the,
uh,
the whole earth would be dead in 50
years or something like that.
But if all the humans died,
the earth would be,
we'd repair itself.
I believe that.
Yeah,
that makes sense.
I mean,
the,
just the massive ants and the jobs that
ants do.
People don't understand,
know gazelles have to be there.
Then that means you have to have
cheetahs.
You have to have something that cleans
things up.
And you know,
ants play a very important role in the
of shit that
we leave around.
I mean,
aunts have,
you know,
when you leave something on the table
and the ants swarm it,
that's they're supposed to do.
They find shit on the ground.
They find dead bodies.
They find everything.
They and they go to work.
What about all of this craziness with
the bees?
It's weird.
It's very weird.
It's weird because there's a bunch of
different theories and no one seems to
know what the fuck it is.
Some people say it's cell phones and
that the extra cell phone signals are
fucking with the bees and I've talked to
experts and they say there's no doubt
about it,
that it has an effect on the bees,
that the frequency that they operate in,
that they can pick up bands of radio
waves and things because their antenna,
I mean they communicate with each other.
We had a thing on fear factor once where
we cover these people and bees and uh,
when we were.
We were out in this place called Sable
ranch and it's a huge ranch and natural
hive of bees was at the ranch.
So there they have all these bees on
these people.
These local bees came flying in like a
giant group of them and they all made a
huge cloud in the sky.
And the a b handlers like,
all right everybody,
let's back away from this.
Everybody get way back.
They've got to work this out.
So they worked it out.
They communicated with each other and
they found out who was who.
And then the local bees like separated
and they let the law,
the bees that were this guy's honeybees,
the train be,
they're never trained,
you know,
the contained bs,
I guess you would say let them go about
their business.
But it's like there was some
communication going on and this guy said
they had to work this out.
Like that's how he described it.
And I go,
what do you mean work it out?
Like,
what's,
what's going on here?
That's incredible.
It was amazing because I,
I,
and what's amazing is that nobody seemed
to give a fuck.
You know,
I,
I was,
I was baffled by like,
are they up there talking?
Are they talking right now?
His bees were like,
they all got together and I was amazed
that this guy knew what was going on,
that he knew that some local bees came
in and he knew that that's all they had
to do.
They just had to get together and talk.
And I'm like,
how often does this happen?
And he's like,
it happens all the time that bees find
out there's some other bs in their area.
Like what the fuck are they finding out?
I guess they send scouts,
maybe they have one.
God's like,
dude,
there's a fucking hundred guys I never
met before.
How does this come out?
And then come back and communicate that
information to get everyone else to come
out.
Yeah.
They say they do it through pheromones.
You know,
there,
there's a lot of um,
there's a lot of confusion about how
they do it and what,
what level of communication they
actually have because they're so alien
to us.
I mean,
they're,
what they fascinating because it using
our.
One of our cell phone networks are part
of this texting each other.
I think they're just getting jacked.
I think our cell phone networks like
Jackhammers,
but they don't,
they can't find them either.
You know,
it's sort of like,
well where are they?
Where are they going?
Well,
they're not disappearing.
They're dying.
They're not breathing properly.
Right?
Yeah.
It's crazy.
And if we don't have bees,
especially,
honeybees were really fucked.
We need to come up with little robot
bees that do a better job than B's.
Little tiny microscopic robots that go
out and pollinate.
Shit.
What is that?
So hard?
Yeah.
Why do you have to have drones to kill
people in Pakistan?
But some drone bees so complex.
If we have this bad ass be that's less
complex and we control that little
motherfucker.
All it has to do is pollinate.
I don't,
you know,
we can make our own hunting.
I'm pretty sure we don't need base for
that.
Right?
Can we figure out a way to make
artificial honey?
Probably not like they say that local
honey,
I'm from the area that you are,
contains a of protection from the local
ailments.
Like say if there's local colds going on
that it would be a good anti a
antioxidant or what not not sure,
but a good prevention from a,
from catching local colds that a raw
honey raw food really is where it's at.
I mean,
the real problem with milk for a lot of
people is the um,
the uh,
the fact that you have to get it
homogenize it.
Pasteurize.
If you get raw milk,
it's way easier to digest.
I don't necessarily know.
I mean crazy.
Well,
I mean that whole thing.
Yeah,
went down in Santa Monica.
I think they're still in.
What happened there was that there's a
Santa Monica co-op or there some place
in Santa Monica that was selling raw
milk and a government like clamped down
ahead.
They like rated the place.
I guess they'd given him a couple of
warnings or maybe a donor like a mellow
rate earlier and they kept,
they kept trying to sell raw milk and
then they finally went in guns blazing
and shut them down.
And there's always lawsuits now.
Yeah.
They get the kind of sound like a
million dollars bail or something crazy.
Right,
right.
Well,
what I have found out those,
that raw milk is still legal.
You can buy raw milk in this country,
in this state.
What did they,
what did the guy do that with some
regulatory issue,
but sprouts in woodland hills has raw
milk.
They do,
yeah.
There's certain companies that in
California sell raw milk.
Huh?
Yeah.
Hold on.
There's a,
there's a,
a,
a famous,
a raw milk company.
And they,
um,
they,
uh,
they list where they sell it and they
sell it at quite a few different places.
Yeah.
And we need to find the law on that
because a raw milk.
I was under the mistaken impression that
it was illegal because they pulled it
out of whole foods foods.
Raw Milk Los Angeles.
Yeah.
Let me see here.
But yeah,
you can get.
There's websites that are out there.
What happened with that guy in Santa
Monica?
Because that was a gnarly situation.
There's actually a raw milk,
a store in Hollywood shout out to the
old PDC hub,
a raw milk store where you can buy raw
milk and La.
Yeah.
Oops.
Every now and then it sickens 10 people
raw milk seconds.
Ten people.
Well,
you know,
thinking about raw milk is,
it's like thing you're not supposed to
be able to take milk and it sits on the
couch or it sits rather,
uh,
in frigerator for a fucking week
and a half.
And it's still good.
That's crazy.
Like that doesn't exist in nature.
You can't take a steak and leave it in
your fridge for a week.
And a half,
it looks like shit smells terrible
because it's rotting,
you know,
and that's that that's going on with
your milk to like at a certain point in
time,
like it's not going to be good anymore.
You can't just put that homogenized,
pasteurized shit.
You just leave it in there.
Weeks later stays good for you,
open the top,
weeks later you smell it.
It's fine.
That's crazy.
I mean we,
we've figured out a way to preserve
things and make them all fucking funky.
Did you have a Milkman when you were a
kid?
For a very brief point in time?
I think my grandparents did because I do
remember it,
but it was,
I don't think it was our house,
but I do remember it.
So I think it was my grandparents,
but they had like a glass bottle with a
foil top.
Yeah,
exactly.
Does mean,
does that even exist anymore?
Somebody must offer that service.
There's always these,
like small companies,
like grass fed is a big issue now with a
lot of people.
Um,
specifically before we end this,
I wanted to find out what is wrong with
what the Paleo guys are saying and in
your opinion,
and like what,
uh,
what,
what is faulty about their thinking,
what's faulty about they're thinking?
Well,
I think that that was problematic for me
is this idea that it's this low,
it's a low carb focus,
right?
It's low carb,
high protein.
I think the focus is to eat like people
eight thousands of years ago because
that's how our body set up essentially
like just vegetables,
the,
uh,
um,
the research on how we ate thousands of
years ago.
Again,
going back to what we talked about
before,
like,
you know,
there's,
there's holes in that.
So is there.
Yeah,
I mean we were hunters and gatherers,
so there's a gathering part to that that
gets overlooked in favor of the hunting
part because that's a little sexier,
I guess it is.
But,
uh,
the idea of eating,
you know,
such a,
such a low,
like the no grain thing,
the no fruit thing,
all of that to,
you know,
focus on the meat,
the saturated fat,
the high protein,
low carbohydrate is,
is sort of in a certain respect is kind
of an extrapolation of the Atkins Diet,
you know,
which is where this whole idea of,
this way of eating,
which helps you lose weight relatively
quickly,
but also,
um,
can cause you problems with ketosis and
eating too much protein which can,
which can be damaging.
And so as a,
you know,
as an athlete,
like I don't know how you're supposed to
function without eating more
carbohydrates.
Like I couldn't do it without eating
plenty of grains and fruit and that's
just speaking from my own experience.
But,
um,
my biggest thing is again,
going back to what we talked about
earlier,
which is,
which is this incredible incidents of
western disease that we have to deal
with here.
You know,
and when people are dropping dead of
heart attacks left and right,
and it's a gigantic problem.
And,
you know,
diabetes,
obesity,
Alzheimer's,
all these kinds of things,
and there are studies that link animal
products to the incidence of these
diseases and that to me it makes more
sense to eat,
plant based and the studies show that
when you eat a plant based diet,
you can actually prevent yourself from
contracting these essentially foodborne
illnesses.
So that's.
So it's not that I'm,
I have some huge beef with Paleo per se.
Um,
I'm just more plant based Diet and
again,
I think there's,
you know,
a lot of cool stuff about Paleo.
Like I love the evolutionary fitness
aspect of it,
you know,
those sort of returned to moving your
body and the kettle balls and the focus
on core strength and how that birth
cross fit and all of that.
I think that's fantastic.
Yeah,
there's,
you know,
and it's certainly,
I think that a plant based diet and the
Paleo Diet have a lot more in common
than they do differences when compared
to a standard American diet for sure.
You know,
standard American diet isn't even really
a diet,
it's just a filler.
I know,
but the problem is that if you ask
people,
90 percent of people,
if you ask them will tell you they eat
healthy,
when in fact it's probably like one
percent of people that actually eat
healthy or everybody wouldn't be keeling
over with heart disease.
You know,
and I think that heart disease starts
when you're a teenager,
you know,
you start clogging those arteries at a
very young age and you hear these
stories of like,
oh,
I had no symptoms and then I killed over
from a heart attack.
Well,
you've been working on that disease for
20 years,
you know what I mean?
And it's a real problem and it just
doesn't need to exist.
And so from everything I've read,
the best way to prevent that is to cut
the meat and dairy out of your diet.
You know,
I don't know how to.
I don't know how to say it any other
way.
So why did the Paleo guys deny this?
Paleo guys seem to point to the fact
that there's an actual benefit to eating
meat and that a vegetarian diet or Vegan
Diet does not have all the nutritional
benefits of a mediating protein eating
diets.
I don't know why they say that because I
don't.
I don't believe that to be true.
I mean,
if they're saying that you can't,
you can't,
you can't thrive on a Vegan Diet.
I mean it's just,
it's an,
it's an ill founded.
It's an ill founded statement.
I mean,
I think even rob himself said,
you know,
lots of guys do well on a Vegan diet and
he said he tried a Vegan diet and it
ultimately he lost a ton of weight.
I think he said he lost a whole bunch of
weight or whatever and I can't remember
why he said he decided to not do it
anymore,
whether he wasn't feeling good or
whatever,
but I'd be interested in knowing what it
was that he was eating because I think
most people that say,
yeah,
I tried a Vegan Diet didn't work for me.
I felt lousy.
Well,
I don't know what that means.
You know,
I mean you can be a junk food vegan and
eat terribly and being the nutrient
deprived for sure.
You know,
so it's not about,
it's not about eating tofurkey and fake
chicken fingers,
it's about the whole foods,
you know,
the whole food,
plant based Diet and that means you
know,
similar to Paleo,
getting rid of the oils,
you know,
or,
or you know,
reducing the oil as well,
not the saturated fats,
but the other fats,
I mean this most,
you know,
most of the plant based oils aren't,
don't have saturated.
I mean coconut oil does or a couple that
do,
but you know,
it's actually still.
Yeah,
exactly.
But,
but those are those also contribute to
arthrosclerosis and stuff like that?
No,
just oils and oils in general.
Coconut oil can continue if you are.
Yeah,
I mean there is a certain contingent of
the whole food plant based Diet movement
that basically say no oils,
no oils in your diet.
What?
But I thought that essential oils are
essential for brain function and
for there are these are,
these are the people that are.
This is like the Dr Esselstyn.
The t Colin Campbell,
like the cores or whatever,
and they're speaking to people that have
suffered heart attacks or you know,
are in seriously poor health and are in
a position where they really need to
reverse the condition that they're in.
So it's an,
it's an extreme situation.
Personally,
I,
you know,
I eat oils,
I put coconut oil on my morning,
vitamax I like olive oil on my dressing
or whatever.
I try not to Overdo it,
I judicious about it,
but I feel like I need that in order to
get the calories that I need to train
the way that I want to train.
Yeah.
Because there's a lot of people that
believe that fats and oils are,
they're critical to,
uh,
to brain function.
Not only that,
there are a very efficient source of
energy,
especially in endurance sports because,
you know,
every gram of fat has much more whatever
it is,
kilojoules of energy than,
than a gram of sugar or carbohydrate
really.
So,
um,
you're better when it's metabolized in a
different way,
way,
you know what I mean?
Like it in an endurance sports,
you're always looking at,
you know,
sort of what,
what zone of exertion your training in
and that can be calculated by heart
rate,
like wearing a heart rate monitor or on
a bike by a power meter that measures
the amount of watts,
like the force that you're exerting on
the pedal.
And you can be very specific about what
your exertion level is and how that
correlates to which energy mechanism
you're using.
And so when you're an endurance athlete,
you want to really emphasize the fat
burning zone,
which is like the lower intensity of the
aerobic anaerobic zone of energy,
which is kind of like just below that,
that level where you feel like you're,
you're getting a little too winded,
you know what I mean?
And that's,
it's a certain level of exertion in
which you're metabolizing fat for energy
as opposed to glycogen.
And if you're metabolizing fat for
energy,
you can essentially go all day.
The more you train that,
that mechanism,
it gets more and more efficient.
Um,
but if you are,
if your exertion ramps up and you're
burning glycogen,
all of a sudden for energy,
you're only going to be able to go about
90 minutes before you run out of fuel.
You can deplete your glycogen stores.
You're Never gonna Deplete your fat
stores.
There's just too much of it.
So you can train your body to burn off
fat.
Instead of training your body to burn
off carbohydrates,
you're training,
you're training your body to utilize fat
for energy.
So it's not like you're,
you're,
you know,
there's a difference between dietary
fat,
subcutaneous fat,
but we all have,
no matter how lean you are and how
matter,
you know,
I've gotten very,
very lean.
You still have a lot of fat in your
system that's available as an energy
resource.
And how do you train your body to do
that by,
by being very specific about the
training zones and the exertion levels
that you're,
uh,
that you're doing,
whether it's running,
swimming or biking.
So for example,
cycling is like a perfect machine for,
for the human because you can rig it all
up to a computer and you can be very,
very specific about what your output is.
You have a heart rate monitor,
you have the bikes these days,
have a computer on it,
right?
So you have your power meter which
registers the force you're exerting on
the pedals and watts.
And then you can extrapolate that out
after a ride,
what your average watts are for that
ride.
And then you balance that against what
your heart rate was at that particular
watts,
what the grade,
you know,
how much elevation gain you have,
what the exterior temperature is.
And you can create these insane graphs
and look at it and like make judgment
calls about where your fitness is,
where your weaknesses are,
and adjust your training program
accordingly.
And so when you're training for
endurance or ultra endurance,
again,
it goes back to really emphasizing that
fat burning zone,
that aerobic zone,
because because the more efficient you
can be at that,
you can,
um,
you can improve your speed without doing
that much speed work.
I'm not,
I'm not saying this very articulately,
but for.
I'll give you an example.
When I first started doing this
endurance stuff out and wanted to stay
in my zone two,
which is the aerobics,
so I would have to keep my heart rate
when I was running below about 1:45.
Initially when I first started running,
I couldn't,
uh,
if I ran faster than like a nine or 9:30
pace,
my ra would go over 1:45.
And when it went over 1:45,
I knew I was no longer in the fat
burning zone that I was getting into the
glycogen burning zone.
But by staying in that specific heart
rate region,
over time,
my pace increased without my heart rate
going up,
which,
which is telling,
which is telling me that I'm becoming a
more efficient athlete at a certain
level of exertion.
My body is becoming faster and more
efficient.
So by training less hard,
less less physical exertion,
you actually improve your boundaries in
a certain respect.
Yeah,
I mean it was explained to me initially
like if you want to go fast first you're
going to have to go slow and build the,
build the foundation of this machine
from the ground up.
And that doesn't mean there isn't a time
and place for speed work and you know,
super exertion work at a,
at a higher intensity zone.
But,
but the key to success in endurance
sports is really emphasizing that,
that aerobics on training and education
efficiency more efficient.
And so for example,
when I first started doing this training
and I'd go out for these crazy long
training sessions,
I come back,
I was starving,
I'd be eating,
you know,
I just couldn't eat enough food.
Now the toll that it,
the tax on my body for doing a similar
workout like four or five years later is
de minimus compared to what it was
before.
So actually my appetite has gone down
even though the training has been the
same,
if not more difficult.
So.
So the body adapts in other words.
Wow.
That is fascinating stuff.
So,
um,
how often are you wearing a heart
monitor while you're training while
you're exercising?
Always.
Always because see,
I never did.
I always buy them and I just fucking
leave them,
sit there and I just work out,
work out hard and then I'm done.
Well and you know,
coming from swimming and what it was
like in the eighties,
you know,
it was always,
a go hard or go home and no pain,
no gain.
It's like if I had an hour to work out
and I was going to go for a run,
just run as hard as I can,
you know,
as fast as I can in that given our.
And that's the best workout then I'm
going to get.
And actually,
you know,
the truth couldn't be more different.
So if you want to get better,
and that's the problem with a lot of
sort of amateur athletes that want to do
marathons or 10 k's or,
or even like shorter distance triathlons
by training,
that way of just kind of using the time
allotted and going as hard as you can in
that allotted period of time,
you're going to reach a certain level of
fitness and aptitude and what you're
trying to do,
but you're very quickly gonna hit a
glass ceiling and you're going to
plateau and you're not going to be able
to break through.
So what is the way to break through,
but we had to break through is to step
it back and really again,
go back to building that foundation from
the ground up and focusing on if you
slow down and really focus on improving
your aerobic efficiency and it's time
consuming,
it takes time to do this.
Um,
then you are building a platform upon
which that speed work,
which you will do later,
is going to catapult you into a new
realm of proficiency.
So it's all about.
It doesn't make sense.
It's.
So it's all about pushing the heart rate
at a certain pace,
maintaining that certain pace for
prolonged periods of time,
and then building up to the point where
you could do that easier and easier and
easier and that is your real big base
and it's not about these wild sprints to
your heart wants to fucking explode.
It's actually about building up your
ability to maintain a a heart rate even
though you're doing more work,
maintained the same heartbreak of 1:45.
Is that weird?
Well,
yeah.
I mean that's just my personal example,
but I mean it,
it requires a different kind of
discipline because you kind of have to
check your ego at the door,
you know what I mean?
And,
and sometimes you want that feeling of
like I just exerted myself,
I feel like I did some work,
I got something done.
And having the discipline to say every
workout has a purpose and the purpose of
this workout is I'm going to run for an
hour and a half and my goal is to never
let my heart rate exceed that zone
threshold.
So say if I'm going to finish the run
and maybe I'm not even gonna feel that
tired,
I might not feel like I was like,
I don't feel like I got anything out of
that and believing in that program and
sticking to it over time to build that
house.
Do you think that that's a good way that
someone should approach a martial arts
as well?
And that like strength and conditioning
for martial arts,
like say kettlebells or something like
that,
they should also do the same sort of
thing.
Maintain A.
Well,
it's a little bit different because
endurance sports are so much about
efficiency of movement,
you know,
and over a prolonged period of time.
Whereas something like Jujitsu or,
or,
or what have you is about explosive
speed,
but at the same time you're going to be
in the ring for a prolonged period of
time.
If you have this sort of lung capacity
and stamina to endure,
you know,
longer than your competitor so that
you're fresher in that last round than
he is,
then you're going to have an advantage.
So I think that what that would mean,
and certainly I'm no expert in martial
arts or what have you,
so I don't want to get schooled for
saying the wrong thing,
but it would seem to me that in the off
season,
um,
or you know quite a bit of time before
you get into your training camps leading
up to a fight,
you would focus on doing a lot of base
aerobic training work to kind of lay
that endurance foundation.
And then you build upon that with the
specific strength and explosive speed
exercises to,
you know,
have that pyramid come to a peak when it
comes to fight day
one of the best fighters in the world.
Uh,
Nick Diaz is a unknown triathlete.
I mean,
he's a,
he's constantly doing massive endurance
work.
And the thing about nick is that he puts
guys a,
puts them into a pace he sets them up.
Like when he's,
uh,
when he,
when he fights,
he pushes a pace that other guys can't
compete with.
Like he uses his endurance.
He uses his verse strong endurance base
as an extra weapon.
It's an extra.
Yeah,
that makes a lot of sense.
because he can,
he can just keep going.
He swimming back from Alcatraz twice.
I mean he's got ridiculous endurance and
because of that it seems like one of the
scariest guys in the world because of
that,
because you know you're not going to
wear them out.
You're never going to wear him out.
It's impossible.
There'll be scrambling deep into the
fifth round while you're gasping for
air.
He'll be fine and he talks shit to you.
Why he's beating on you sort of terrible
time were alive at the same time.
I'm sure he follows a basically a Vegan
diet as well.
That's what I thought.
Yeah,
he does it for performance reasons.
I think jake shields does as well.
I think jake may eat eggs occasionally,
but I think that's it for a lot of
people that don't know.
I didn't know until I was 30 that uh,
when you have an egg that's not like
something died,
the chickens just lay those eggs and if
they're not fertilized by the mail
through so he doesn't get in the
henhouse those eggs or just go to waste
beginning of them.
You don't even have bad Karma Dude.
Um,
what could someone.
Is there a book that someone could read
about this?
Uh,
this conditioning thing?
I know that for a lot of people that do
Jujitsu,
this is gonna be a really fascinating
for a lot of people that do anything
athletic.
What,
what is a good book that they could read
about heart rates and.
Well,
they can read,
they can read.
My book will tell us what it is.
What's your book?
My book is called finding ultra.
Actually,
can I grab it?
I have,
yeah,
please do.
I would love to read it.
Here's it on the screen.
Well,
boom.
And is this,
uh,
your life story?
Is it also.
Yeah.
I mean,
this is
as a,
it's essentially,
it's essentially memoir.
It's like my personal story,
but it has a lot about,
um,
how I sort of reinvented myself as an
athlete and how I had to kind of relearn
some certain principles about fitness
that I grappled with and didn't
understand initially that I'm sort of
allowed me,
I believe,
to reach a new level of fitness sites
that I certainly didn't think was
possible,
particularly as a middle aged guy.
And you did this all through that method
of building up the aerobic base
specific thing that is,
you know,
not what most people are training for,
but the kind of principles that we were
just talking about I think are
applicable to,
you know,
the,
the sort of weekend warrior athlete,
whether you want to go out and be able
to feel good in your pickup basketball
game or,
or touch football or whatever it is.
Um,
it's how to use your time crunched a
days effectively.
You know,
rather than just going out haphazardly
and saying,
I'm going to blast this 30 minutes on
the treadmill and do it time and time
again and wonder why you're never
getting any faster.
So,
um,
so people can get any answers to any
questions about conditioning and what
you learned from finding ultra.
Can they get that on Amazon?
And it's everywhere.
It's on Amazon,
Barnes and noble.
And if people want to reach you,
it's rich.
Roll our Ich,
not rick,
not fucking Rick Astley.
This is not a joke.
Rich Roll.
The real rich roll.
Just like the real rich Ross,
but a different God.
And you could find rich roll on twitter.
Just rich roll R I c h a r o l is it the
best way to get ahold of you?
The best information on facebook to my
websites.
Rich Roll R I C H r o l l.
well listen man,
your story's an awesome story.
I love a comeback.
I love,
I love a guy who figured something out
in his life and makes a change and then
spreads that information and you're
inspirational dude.
And uh,
having you on the podcast is really cool
and I would love to do this again if you
want to come in again.
Feeling's mutual and we keep talking
about this forever.
I love it.
Yeah.
But I,
I had to stop myself from the endurance
questions.
I would have bored the fuck of it.
Like for my own technical man.
I don't know if people really are going
to be that.
Some people will hopefully,
um,
uh,
thank you.
Uh,
thank you very much man.
Really appreciate it.
So rich roll.
I follow him on twitter.
Go to [inaudible] dot tv,
you dirty bitches and pick yourself up
some funky ass cat tee shirts.
Uh,
and uh,
and they come with a free sticker to.
So you put it on your call so people
come with a free steak or what are you?
I thought you said you're sending those
stickers so they pay for that sticker.
Hooker.
Go get yourself a sticker.
But those,
uh,
you can identify fellow squatters and
parking lots.
And Shit's good.
You.
What's up?
Guy Just tweeted me.
So that is a neighbor who had never met
before,
knocked on his door when he heard he was
listening to this podcast.
You heard my voice booming out of his
living room.
And so the neighbor knocked.
I was like,
man,
I fucking love that podcast.
So thanks everybody for you know,
like I can't thank you guys enough for
being the coolest crowds ever.
Sacramento was fucking completely off
the chain.
I literally,
uh,
I never imagined that we would have
these kinds of crowds on a regular
basis.
It's really amazing and we appreciate
the fuck out of him.
And what I said earlier is not lip
service.
I really do feel a massive obligation to
you guys.
I know that this has become a part of
your life and it's supportive of our
life too and everything we're doing,
Brian and I is moving towards making
sure we just keep doing more of this,
keep digging deeper,
keeping having more people,
more cool people like rich roll come on
the show and tomorrow Mac Danzig will be
on,
as I said as well the director of
cocaine cowboys,
Billy Corbin,
who is also a cool motherfucker.
Thanks to thanks to era alienware MMA
for sending us some,
some cool ass laptops that Brian runs
all the youtube videos on.
If you go to follow them on twitter,
alien mma on twitter,
and thanks to onnit.com,
use the code name,
Rogan O,
n,
n I t the code Brogan will save you 10
percent off any and all supplements.
All right,
you fucking freaks tomorrow.
We have a double podcast day.
So first we'll be Mac Danzig and then it
will be Joey Diaz and Billy Corbin.
And then we have a spectacular show
tomorrow night at the Ice House comedy
club.
It is dom irrera.
It is Duncan Trussell,
Doug Benson,
Brian Red Band,
Joey Diaz.
The list goes on and whoever winds up
coming by,
they could,
they could get onstage to.
Alright,
see you tomorrow folks without a key.